if anybody's got the answers it's jocko
you got any answers oh uh i'm not quite
so sure about that
i'm not sure how this movie ends this
is the dumbest [ __ ] movie ever do you
know magic the gathering is now racist i
don't know what magic the gathering is
it's some
dorky game that that nerds play oh sorry
how is it how is it racist
um i don't know it was just re i only
saw the title of the article that
they're trying to cancel magic the
gathering i'm like oh christ
i thought that's what you guys liked i
thought they liked magic the gathering
i i have no idea everything's
everything's everything's problematic
everyone's getting canceled it's amazing
how many people did blackface
yeah it's very strange it's very strange
it's it's very strange i was on it was
on prime time tv
right yeah a bunch of times yeah i mean
like in the modern world
prime time tv jimmy fallon was doing
well he's doing a chris
rock impression which by the way you
used to be able to do
when i was in high school my friends
were mr t for halloween nobody gave a
[ __ ]
nobody was like jimmy what's wrong with
you everybody's like oh you're mr t for
halloween
it was never like a problem it's very
it's a very strange thing
you know like you can do white face no
problem
here it is what is this magic the
gathering invoke prejudice card
that's a it's an enchantment card which
restricts the casters
opponents only using summons that match
the skin color of their opposing
creatures
huh this is if you brought me on to talk
about this i should leave now
about about magic the gathering and this
is why i'm here man we're in a bad way
it shows how [ __ ] up everything is
yeah
there's a lot of thin skin out there
right now apparently i just don't
i mean it seems like a perfect storm
like if you wanted to engineer the
downfall of society
you would do it in several steps you
would have a reality show president
where everybody's mad at them and and
then all the
liberals get their feathers in a ruffle
and everybody gets real super uptight
and
then there's this big divide between the
left and the right that's kind of
you know manufactured and then you'd
have this
disease just lock everyone inside yeah
unprecedented lock
shut down the economy force people to
not work
so if your business falls apart you
could be the most hard-working diligent
disciplined person who's always at work
an hour early always has your
eyes dotted and your t's crossed you
still go broke you're still
[ __ ] and then you have this george
floyd thing
and then boom it just ignites the power
keg
the other thing that you have to wrap
around all this is
this social media which is you know
i'm only going to post things that are
just gonna completely make everyone that
sees whatever i'm posting
emotional and and filled with rage
whether you're on the left or you're on
the right
my goal is to enrage people that's the
goal and then that just gets spun up
over and over so you're taking all these
little incidents
and you're multiplying times thousands
and thousands of views
and and then on top of that mainstream
media
is the same thing right it's not like
there's this huge difference between
what the mainstream media shows and what
social media they're both exposed to
emotional media just trying to make
people emotional
which is the worst possible thing no one
makes good decisions when they're
emotional
no i spent my adult life trying to train
humans to not get emotional in pressure
situations why because
it's gonna end up bad every single time
every single time
and yet that's what our that's what our
society is based on right now
but it's based on these emotional
reactions yeah because of social media i
think and because of things like youtube
and user created content where anybody
can kind of
make videos so many things are vying for
folks attention
that mainstream media has resorted to
clickbaity
type [ __ ] whether it's new york times
articles
which you know used to be beyond
reproach that they're they've gone
social justice warrior and click baity
and all these other websites are 100
clickbaity that's the only way they can
get people to pay attention
like i saw like the dumbest [ __ ]
article
i couldn't believe how dumb it was it
was an article on ozark
it's like has ozark been canceled and
i'm like [ __ ] they canceled that show
that show's amazing
so then i click on the article the
entire article is about a guy who
couldn't
find season one on ozark because there
was a glitch
and then he found it and so it's not
okay so the whole article was just
[ __ ] yeah
but they got me they get everybody they
got you to click they got their
advertising dollars because they can
show the
engagement with the audience exactly
well here's a good one cnn
showed a guy got shot yesterday in san
bernardino
um a hispanic man got shot in san
bernardino so that's the title
the title of the article is hispanic man
gets gunned down by the police in san
bernardino
what they leave out is the guy had a gun
and was shooting at the cops so this
guy's got a gun
there's photos of this gentleman with a
gun and there's a cop
on his knees about to shoot the guy the
guy standing in front of a gas station
there's gas pumps i mean i mean maybe he
felt like they wouldn't shoot at him
because the gas tanks were right behind
him the the pumps were right behind him
but why would they leave that out guy
with gun
in gun fight with cops dies is the right
title not hispanic man gunned down by
cops like
they're literally trying to incite anger
and violence they know that you read
that and you say hispanic man
shot by cops like these [ __ ]
they're murderers they won't stop
and they leave out this picture of this
man with a gun pointing it
you're looking at me like i'm gonna say
some kind of really profound answer i
got nothing for you
because because you're exactly right
that what is it what do they
set up that headline for it's a outrage
people yeah anyone that actually opens
it up and reads
would actually probably say something
like hmm sounds like the cops did a good
job on that one and killed a bad guy
before he blew up a gas station and
it killed a bunch of innocent people but
that's that's obviously not that i mean
i think if you try to write a headline
the other way
of how these heroic cops face man with
gun
eliminate him before he can cause terror
in this neighborhood
that would be a nice headline to read
but you're not going to see it you're
not going to do that
not today because it's not going to
drive enough people crazy today
if your wife tweets all lives matter
you can get you can get fired
it doesn't even have to be you anymore
yeah all lives matter just imagine a
time
where saying all lives matter is so
controversial
that you could get fired didn't that
happen to a soccer player or something
yes a soccer player's wife tweeted
something like that
yeah the guy who runs the kings or the
guy who's the commentator for the kings
they fired him
you know and then this is a lot of it is
this
right so people are feeling a certain
way
and they're not they're not like this
girl that wrote all lives matter
do you think that was her clandestine
way of showing that she's all about
white pride you know what i mean no she
was thinking hey everyone matters she's
probably having some nice thoughts
you know she's but then all of a sudden
no this chick is evil
right for doing this and i think there's
a lot of that i think there's a lot of
people that
i think most people are pretty sane
i think most people are pretty
reasonable i think you know anybody
looking at at the george floyd case like
yeah that's completely wrong
that's disgusting it's horrible tainus
to watch i haven't heard anyone say
other anything other than that
so how are we just getting so completely
divided on this whole thing and start
attacking people
start attacking each other just over
over absolutely everything
that's a good point because this is
literally a case where no one
is saying there's nothing wrong with
that cop did no one
no one zero people zero people but yet
everybody's still
at each other's throats zero people have
have
stuck up that guy in any way shape or
form even law enforcement no law
enforcement people say you gotta
understand
this is how you control a man you gotta
lean on his neck for about eight minutes
40
40 45 seconds 46 seconds no one's saying
that and unfortunately what you know
what
you know what they're saying they're
saying defund the police
yeah they're saying no more choke holds
right
which i think is crazy it's crazy yeah
if you want to get
someone to be under control and you
can't choke them
you know what you have to do you have to
hit them in the head with a baton
yeah seven times and you got to risk
giving them brain damage
permanently injuring them if people know
what they're doing
i mean obviously if people know what
they're doing oh we'll put a choke on
they'll wake up they'll be cuffed yeah
we're all good yeah obviously
but you know it's the people that are
doing it wrong
is the problem the people that shouldn't
be doing in the first place it's
untrained people
it's but if you're if you're not you're
a cop and you're a fight for your life
and
you can't use chokeholds that's
[ __ ] crazy you're gonna get shot and
killed or somebody else is going to get
shot and killed someone's going to take
your gun
yeah and and the the idea of defund the
police and i i
i understand the premise okay and this
is once again
where many people that say defund the
police they don't mean hey just
get rid of police of course there's a
there's a fraction of people that are
saying defund the police means we don't
want any more police anymore
there's a portion of people saying that
there's some people are saying well
if we defund the police we can relocate
some of that money and we can
do you know better schools and we can
put money into the infrastructure inside
these neighborhoods
but here's the problem you know what the
police need more than anything else they
need money for training
and the way the police departments are
set up
they do the most ridiculously
minuscule amount of training for what
their job is so
as you know i was in the seal teams we
would train for 18 months
18 months we were trained to go on a
six-month deployment
cops they train they get like
two hours or four hours of combatives
training
a year a year
that's that's complete insanity insanity
it's complete insanity
the thing i've been saying is cops
should train
one-fifth of the time one-fifth of the
time you should be training whether it's
two hours a day four times a week or
whether it's one day a week
where you're gonna go and you're gonna
go through scenarios you're gonna do
combatives you're gonna work with
simunition you're gonna do de-escalation
drills
because it's really hard i mean being a
cop is i think is the hardest job in the
world and by the way they're not gonna
have to worry about defunding the police
because
no one's gonna wanna be a cop anymore
who is gonna be fired up to be a cop
right now who's gonna think
you know what when i grow up i wanna be
hated
by entire you know by a massive portion
of the country
i want to be viewed as someone that's uh
that kills innocent people
the the the recruiting in cop for for
police is going to go down
so hard it's going to be ridiculous it's
going to be ridiculous and then who are
you getting there
you're going to get people that are
worse level people
worst level humans are going to show up
to be cops so
the training piece though
they should do very very scenario driven
training
right where you come into a room and
this isn't like super expensive stuff
either
you come into a room there's a person
there
they appear to be compliant you ask you
you learn how to talk to them
you very quickly learn that instead of
yelling them out of the out of the gate
you say hey man what's going on
hey what's your name you know what
what's going on we got a call here is
everything okay
you just immediately de-escalate then
you learn what to do when they're not
when they don't respond the way you want
them to respond then you learn what to
do
when they start to do something drastic
what's the best thing for you
and you play through these scenarios
it's just like jiu-jitsu
in the fact that what makes jiu-jitsu
good what makes jiu-jitsu good is we can
go hard against each other
over and over again and not really get
hurt not really get killed so you get
really good at it
that's what you need to do in training
for police you need to go through these
tough scenarios
over and over again because you do get
better at it
you do get better at it you become you
learn how to
mentally detach and not get emotional
and realize that there's other things
that are happening
when you see the the george floyd case
uh a couple of other cops too i think
two of the other guys were complete
rookies
right they had been on the force for a
very short period of time
no one in that group of four obviously
you got the killer himself
he's he's actually conducting the act
but all the other guys are
not paying attention they're they're all
emotional themselves hey stay back and
and they're probably watching him saying
what's why isn't that guy moving and
they're just
caught up in it whereas if someone would
have showed up on the scene or one of
those guys
had been through some good training in
their life they would have said
what's happening here hold on my partner
over there has been on this guy for
two minutes he's not moving anymore i'm
gonna walk over and say hey man let me
take over
i got this go over there decompress this
takes training you have to train people
and i got
i saw this over and over again in the
seal teams training guys
you get a young kid that's coming
through training for the first time and
they go into a room and they're
getting shot with simunition bullets or
there's someone yelling and screaming or
they
we'd put we'd put arabic women coming
walking out of rooms we'd have people
get blown up with wounds
we would do this to them over and over
again
so they realize okay i just got to relax
i got to take a step back
i got to detach from this situation so i
can process what's happening and i can
make a good decision
because as i said earlier no one is
making a good decision
when they're panicked when they're
freaked out when they're scared
as a jiu jitsu guy when someone puts
hands on you you're not
actually scared right you're like oh
okay i know what to do here
if you don't know jujitsu if you've
never had someone grab you before or you
haven't had someone grab you
in 17 months or 14 months no one's laid
hands on you because you got a badge and
a gun so people when you tell them to do
something 95
of the time they go okay yeah i don't
want to get in trouble but then somebody
grabs you
you're instantly your your emotions are
spiked your adrenaline spiked
and the only way to overcome that is
through
consistent training that that happens on
a regular basis
you can't just train somebody one time
it's like ring rust you know you can't
just train somebody one time and oh now
i don't need a train anymore
no you need to do continuous training so
so that fact right there we
if we want to if we want to help the
police through these situations
we need to invest more money into them
we need to get them better training
we need to pull them out of the field
to train and pull them out of the field
to decompress
because you ever done a ride-along
no like you whether you're doing a ride
along whether you're going into any
situation where you're thinking you
could be killed
and even it's just a remote chance but
you're doing that
all the time all the time and you're
hearing you're seeing on the news you're
oh you hear this oh your buddy got shot
your buddy got whatever
this other guy got you know take his gun
taken away like that stuff happens
that stuff happens people get killed i
mean there's been
i think there's been 31 cops killed
this year 31 cops killed this year and
a lot of those that's not including you
know like a car accident or
covid there's been a bunch of coveted
but just people that have been
engaged with bad guys and they got
killed so you're
a cop when another cop gets killed
you're thinking that could be you
so that's your mindset and that mindset
builds and that mindset
builds and you're working 10 hour days
and you're working 12-hour days
and there's no training and there's no
breaks
where do you end up right where do you
end up you end up being a little bit
paranoid you end up being a little bit
angry what happens when you get in a
fight with your wife
you know it's like all these things you
add them together
it's a freaking hard job and from a
from a like an entire
systemic way of training and recruiting
and
and keeping police ready to do their job
whatever that job entails because let's
face it most of the time that
job entails well i guess most of the
time it entails hey
i'm gonna go have a bad i'm about to go
have a bad relationship with another
human being that's what's about to
happen right
whether i'm pulling you over whether i'm
i've been called to your house because
you were yelling and screaming and
people heard your wife screaming or
whatever
that's what's happening i'm showing up
in a bad relationship you don't like me
and i already don't like you that's
where we start
that's where we start so we got to train
people for that we also got to train
them for all the times that they go into
help people save people they're the
first people on the scenic car accidents
people are bleeding out we got to train
them for that and then they have to also
be trained for
hey this is a bad guy that's gonna this
is the guy that you just talked about at
a gas station
with a weapon that wants to kill a bunch
of people
you got to be prepared for that whole
spectrum as a police officer and yet we
send them to a
three month long police academy and then
we send them out in the street and
that's what they do
day in day out day in day out
it seems to me that they need to be
vetted too much better than they are now
just like the seals like you can't get
through buds unless you
are a superior human being you have to
be able to tolerate
a bunch of [ __ ] that most people are
going to fall apart during
and this is this seems to me that this
is a great way
to weed out people that just don't have
it
yeah there's well one thing that's
interesting just from a physical
perspective most police departments
don't even have
a minimum physical requirement to
continue to be on the force
you have to be at a certain level to
graduate from the academies but
oftentimes there's no
standard beyond that yeah i've seen cops
before that we're like this is hilarious
like
what is going to stop someone from
closing the distance on you like you you
ain't get into that gun
yep but the mental aspect is stuff
that you can get better at yes you can
get better at it but you only get better
at it
through training right and you only get
really comfortable
through training a lot and yet we put
these people in these horrible positions
over and over and over again
and we get we don't give them the proper
training and now there's these
politicians that because of the
current social climate they're
encouraged
to want to defund the police that's a
great way for them
to get brownie points from their
constituents
the people want the police to fund it
which is the one
it's the dumbest idea i've ever heard in
my life it's it's so crazy that this is
actually gaining steam to the point
where
in minneapolis because they're trying to
quiet down the mob they've actually gone
ahead and done it
what the [ __ ] is minneapolis going to
look like in a year from now it's going
to look like mad max
i mean it's going to be crazy that's
going to be it's going to be crazy it's
going to be uh
you know criminals will go there to
commit crimes if there's no
if there's no police there are you crazy
by the way this jocko energy drink is
the [ __ ]
that's very legit right
um yeah i just don't understand where
they think this game ends
i don't think they've planned it out
they're not playing chess the
the other the other thing that you know
you're talking about this
brownie points for the politicians and
and there's brownie points
and there's people trying to create
sides it's my side versus your side and
that's a completely
political thing right and all that does
is increase
the divide between the police
and the civilians and and this reminds
me a lot of
of a counterinsurgency right so counter
insurgency the insurgents are you know
bad guys inside of a
country the country's not bad there's
some bad guys in a country
so what you have to do is you actually
have to go out and build relationships
with the good people inside that country
so that the good people inside that
country
can help you get rid of the bad people
what happens if you go out and this so
this is ramadi iraq this is
my last deployment to iraq there's a
bunch of just totally normal
good people iraqi people that are
living in the city of ramadi what do
they want to do you know what they want
to do
they want to send their kids to school
they want to run their
little market they want to do whatever
that whatever is that they do that's
what they want to do they have the same
goal as a normal family they're just a
normal bunch of people
and inside that group of people there's
a bunch of bad people and these are
insurgents some of them are foreign
fighters some of them are foreign regime
elements from saddam but they're bad
and they want to create chaos and mayhem
so
americans we go in there if we go in
there
super heavy-handed and while i go to
capture
or kill one bad guy i kill or maim
a couple of those normal civilians what
happens
well a couple of those normal civilians
family go wait you guys aren't good
you guys are bad you guys just killed my
brother and he didn't do anything wrong
and then we do it again and then we do
it again and then we do it again
and each time that we do this we're
we're creating more
animosity from the local populace who by
the way like i said they're just nor
good normal people so what we had to do
is really focus on going out and
building relationships with the local
populace
how do we do that and one of the things
this this happened after i left but you
remember the surge that took place and
they sent a bunch more troops over there
part of the reason that they sent that
surge and part of the reason that that
was
allowed to happen was because the battle
of ramadi where i fought
went very well and since it went well
people said well
maybe maybe we can pull this off so they
sent more troops
and one of the directives that general
petraeus gave
is he said there can be no more drive-by
counter insurgency
and what he meant that by that was when
you go to a neighborhood
you can't just drive through the
neighborhood in your humvee in your
bulletproof humvee with your windows up
drive through show of force and then
leave
that that doesn't work what you have to
do is stop your vehicles you have to get
out
you have to talk to the local populace
you have to ask them what's going on you
have to ask them if they need anything
you have to build relationships with the
local populist the good local populist
that just wants those insurgents out of
there and that's
what i don't see happening and the more
we
increase this divide between the police
and the civilians
the worse that's going to get and so the
police have to start doing a better job
of outreach of hey you know i asked you
if you did a ride-along
they should be offering ride-alongs all
the time to the local kids
17-year-old kids 15 year old kids hey
come and see what my job is like come
and help me out
that 15 year old kid he knows who the
bad actors are he knows who the good
kids are
you know bring that kid along on a ride
along let him see what it looks like
from your ankle get out
meet the parents meet the families
that's
where we're failing to build
relationships
between the police and the civilians and
that causes
that that causes these problems i think
you're 100 correct but i don't hear
anybody repeating what you're saying
that's what's terrifying to me i think
everything you're saying is
logical it makes sense it comes from
experience i don't hear anybody saying
this
yeah and well i think maybe it's because
people just don't recognize what's
happening because they're too in it
right they're too in it they're they're
wrapped up in it
and and that's another part you know i
talked about recruiting who you
recruiting
recruit those kids recruit those kids
but you
have to build a relationship with them
before you can at before anyone's gonna
go into the police and look the i think
it's the i think it's the la police
department if you look at the la police
department
compared to the racial makeup of la they
they're pretty equivalent and they're
pretty equivalent on purpose
they do that for a reason so you got to
get that you got to continue to build
that those relationships so that
we talk to one another you know we
actually
communicate with each other because any
time
you know i'm allowed to sit over here in
my area and you're sitting over there in
your area
we're building animosity we build that
kind of animosity between each other
and now the littlest thing the littlest
thing i mean there was a woman
that was killed in minneapolis like two
two three years ago do you remember this
one
yes female like a yoga instructor
called the police the police called the
police to report a disturbance police
showed up and
there's no video no footage she gets
killed by the cops
she gets killed by the cops it's insane
that that these things happen but we
also have to remember
what like i said what is a police
officer thinking about
and what kind of training and we give
them and what kind of psychological
screening to your point what kind of
strike
and it's not just one time psychological
screening because guess what
people get burnt out and it happens at
different times to different people
you take 35 guys in combat i've got some
guys at the end of a six month
deployment there you know what they're
telling me can i stay longer i'm doing
fine
you get one month into that deployment
you've got other guys that are saying
hey do you need anyone to head home
early right that happens
so you think in a police force of a
thousand people or whatever
size your police force is you're gonna
have some people that are
steady mentally stable they can deal
with it
they can go they can they can be an
officer-involved shooting today and
tomorrow they can go back to their job
and be perfectly fine
there's other people they could never
work again after they're an
officer-involved shooting
what kind of investment are we making
into this psychological health
of police and look i i hope it doesn't
sound like i'm sitting here
just putting it all on the police
because
everyone is playing a role in this and
one of the things that you need to look
at as well is
how to get arrested right
there should be a public service course
on how you should get arrested
this is what you should do if the cops
are pulling you over if the cops ask you
if the cops approach you about something
here's what you should think
one of the things you should think is
okay this cop may not be bad this cop
may be looking out for my welfare right
now that's a great hopeful thought
the other thing that you have to think
is kind of worst case scenario
this cop might be agitated this cop
might be looking for somebody that fits
my description
this cop might might have just been in a
fight with his wife he might have just
lost a partner there's a million bad
things
use that scenario in your head use that
scenario in your head
to to contemplate how you're going to
interact with a police officer
which is you know what they're looking
at they're looking at your hands
you know why because that's where the
threat comes from the threat comes from
your hands so when you're making quick
movement with your hands
don't do that listen to what they say
move
move slowly when you move this should be
public service the police should be
putting out hey
if you interact with the police we hate
to have to say this but since our police
sometimes are in bad situations here's
some things we recommend and we highly
suggest and we beg
we beg that you do this we beg because
what happens to these cops when they
kill somebody
what happens to them their their lives
are totally destroyed well that was the
thing about that guy
in minneapolis he'd already killed
people he'd already been involved and i
think it's at least two shootings
and he had more than a dozen complaints
against him
yeah not good i mean it's obvious by the
end
by the end result yeah that's the the
type of guy he was
it's pretty obvious but the the fact
that he was able to do that to a man
the guy's literally calling out to his
dead mother
you know i mean the the type of man that
can stay on someone's neck while they're
doing that when all that guy did was
have a counterfeit
20 bill that's it
this is where when you talk about
psychological yeah screening
and that that's why i'm saying it has to
be it has to be constant
yeah because people people change
yeah right and red flags i mean
like you said hindsight's 20 20 we're
looking at this case now we're going oh
who the hell let's this guy continue to
police
and by the way interestingly enough if
you talk to internal affairs at police
departments
the vast majority of the complaints that
they get about
other about police are from police so
they complain
they report each other that's little
known fact most of the most the reports
don't come from
the civilians out there saying hey this
happened or that happened most of the
time it's cops saying hey
this guy was out of line here well
that's that's a good sign
this it just it doesn't look rosy when
i'm looking at the future i don't i
don't
see a way during this climate
well what what scares me the most is
i don't see a way if we don't talk to
each other
that's where there's no solution because
you know
look for every 10 viral video that you
see
of a of a cop hitting somebody with a
baton
or a rider throwing something through a
window for every 10 of those viral
videos
there's another viral video that has
you know the guy with the free hugs
t-shirt on that's out
talking to the cops and saying hey you
know i i get it and they're
communicating with each other and
talking and
when you communicate with people it's
just like a hostage rescue basic
technique you want to humanize
you want to humanize instead of
dehumanize and right now
we're just dehumanizing each other
completely and that's what scares me
more than anything else
is if we can't talk to each other
because look you take the most
hardened uh soldier in war
some you know some bad ass soldier
that's done four deployments
six deployments whatever and you put
them into a room
with a kid and a mom an iraqi kid or mom
or an afghan kid and mom
and you put them in that room and say
hey sit here for 15 minutes and find out
what they're about here's an interpreter
that that guy's going to come out of
there going yeah i get where they're
coming from
it's and same thing vice versa you take
a hardened jihadist and you say hey
talk to this guy over here about what
he's trying to do inside your country
well
just just just talk to him when you open
up the communications and are you going
to get some extremists on both ends
yes you will so maybe i shouldn't have
said the most hardened
uh soldier and the most hardened because
at the you know what the most hardened
soldier becomes a killer becomes a
killer that that happens
happens all the time you know i i
i shouldn't say it happens all time it
happens from time to time that's how you
get the milai massacre
it happens the the most hardened
jihadist they're not gonna change their
mind
they're not gonna come to any any
rose-colored view
of america but
barring those total extremes you've got
people
you got a few other human beings and if
you can get them to talk to each other
they can find consensus they can find
common ground but if they're not talking
to each other
then we don't move it make any progress
and what to your whole
kind of point about what's happening
right now there's less
and less communication between people
open communication
because if you if you talk to uh someone
and they say the cops did this this and
this and you say oh
okay explain to me what happened tell me
what went down and then you say hey let
me tell you what it's like for b
for a cop being a cop when he sees that
when he sees something going on
you know how many domestic violence
cases happen
and the person shows up and they're
getting assaulted
by both parties
so maybe that's what you're this comp
was thinking when he showed up
and saw your mom in this situation and
did this to your dad
right like this is real conversations
but we don't
we don't have them and not only we don't
have them it seems like
it seems like there's forces that are
actively trying to prevent us from
talking
to each other from sitting down at a
table and saying
hey man what tell me what's going on
what forces
who wants who wants the country to be
divided it's the people that you're
talking about earlier that
that how do they score points how do i
score points
with this group how do i score points
with the other group it's by making
making everything as divisive as
possible it's
it's it's horrible to watch man it's
sickening to watch
i was reading a whole series of tweets
where there's a journalist
that was talking about how um
cops shooting black men is a real
problem but another real problem that's
not being discussed by this
black lives matter group is black on
black crime
and how do we stop all the murders that
are taking place in chicago and this
this is something that should be
discussed
and this guy was getting attacked and
one of the one of the
another journalist is literally tweeting
at him saying
you have been told not to discuss this
but yet he ignores the these commands
that that he should not discuss
is a very real issue as if somehow or
another bringing up another
issue that is also a problem diminishes
the original issue of this guy getting
killed by cops
which of course it doesn't yeah but this
the idea is that
there's problems there's real problems
and it's not
just the cops killing these people
there's there's
look the cop killed this guy in
minneapolis
he didn't do anything in seattle how the
[ __ ] did that [ __ ] happen in seattle
well it happened in seattle because of
this reactionary world
where where one person does something
somewhere
it gets through social media it gets
through the mainstream media it becomes
this
this huge inflammatory subject and then
the next thing you know
windows are getting smashed things are
getting lit on fire cars are getting
turned over blocks are getting taken
and that's where we find ourselves i
think it was may 29th
there was a cop killed i want to say in
texas
and he was killed when they rolled into
a scene
they got they got a call hey suspicious
person running through the neighborhood
they roll up on the scene they start a
couple a few cops
are now searching for this guy and they
see a building
with an open door they go okay let's
that
maybe he's in there let's go clear this
building with an open door they go in
this building with an open door
there's shots fired one of the cops
killed one of the other cops
so so just you know friendly fire
death
that right there if you if you take that
and you just extrapolate that
over how hard it is to be a police
officer
that you can be going into a building
and you shoot
one of your friends because
you think they're bad that is a
real problem that's how hard this job is
my point is that's how hard this job is
but
we have to do a better job of explaining
that we have to do a better job of
explaining how hard this job is
as far as the uh hey don't talk about
black on black violence i was trying i
was talking
with my podcast bro
echo charles who's a black guy and we
were talking about that
and i said you know i think it might
have a little bit to do with this
if you are if you're watching ufc and
there's two guys that are
fighting and the round ends
like just just at the end of the round
all of a sudden
the referee comes in and like punches
one of the like
like just just muay thai kicks a guy in
the head and knocks him out
everyone would be completely utterly
outraged about this right
because of course that guy wasn't in the
game what's that guy doing right so i
think
there's a little bit of that that's
that's the the referee
is supposed to not do that
and when you see a cop the thought is
hey that guy's like
that guy's viewed as a referee that
guy's not supposed to be doing this
so i think that is kind of where some of
that
that that outrage comes from because
this is a cop this isn't supposed to be
happening here
this this guy is no not supposed to be
killing people
right and he did
that's also that the cop is just a
person who has this extraordinary
power yes extraordinary responsibility
too right
what's terrifying to me is that when i'm
looking at this idea to defund the
police
and then i'm thinking like what are
these what do these neighborhoods
look like if you wind up doing that
and then how do you get back out of that
what do you do refund the police do you
do ramp it up and do it better next time
i mean this is a long process you're
looking at a lot of trial and error
here over you know perhaps multiple
years before they figure out what
what they [ __ ] up yeah and i i know
there's some there's some
city i think it's in new jersey that
camden yes that completely disband
dismantled their police but then they
rebuilt a new police department and
and i actually get that like you could
get a department that was so completely
and utterly corrupt
that you said you know what we're
getting rid of all of them did you ever
see cocaine cowboys
no great documentary but one of the
things it talks about is the corruption
during the cocaine era of the 80s where
the entire
graduating police force the entire from
the
police academy the entire graduating
year
everyone was either murdered or went to
jail for corruption
everyone the entire graduating class
that's how bad it was yeah so if you
have that kind of
if you have that kind of problem you
might get his mail out you might want to
dismantle that police force you know
what happens in the seal team sometimes
sometimes there's a platoon that's so
bad that they just they just dismantle
the whole platoon how
how often is that very rarely but it
does happen really yep and what causes
something like that usually
they're well the the problem is bad
leadership it's always bad leadership
because you can take a bunch of
knuckleheads and you give them a good
leader
and they'll do they'll do fine so it's
always comes down to the leadership
so sometimes they'll replace a leader
but if the
and usually when they replace leader
you'll watch the platoon will turn
around almost instantly
because someone steps in and says all
right here's what we're doing here's how
we're doing it
and they they make that change but
sometimes you have just
like a bad platoon and they say you know
what you guys are done
it seems incredibly difficult to be a
good leader
one of the one of the more interesting
things about what you're doing uh
with your platform whether it's your
podcast or the
instagram videos you put out you're
showing
what good leadership is there's not
a lot of people when you look at if you
get a thousand people
how many of those people are going to be
a real
good leader well this is what's this is
what has become my
career after the seal teams because i
got very very lucky in the seal teams
very very lucky first of all my whole
career was just luck i was the luckiest
guy ever in the seal teams
and i happen to be in the right places
at the right times
and i got some great experience in some
very tough situations
and then the last thing that i did in
the seal teams for
almost the last three years i was in was
i ran the training
the tactical training not the training
where guys carry boats on their head and
carry logs around but i didn't do that
i didn't i went through it but i didn't
run that training i ran the training
where
everything i was talking about you're
running scenarios you're putting people
in bad situations you're using
simunition you're doing all these things
so i got to see over and over again
leaders
get put into pressure situations and how
their leaders responded and how the team
responds to that leader and what
these different things wash out how they
wash out and what's interesting is
and what i really realized when i was in
that position
is that their leadership is a
skill and you can get better at it now
just like fighting just like jiu jitsu
there's certain people that have a
natural propensity to be good at you got
some let's say someone's really strong
right they're gonna have an advantage
let's say someone's super flexible
they're gonna have a little advantage
let's say someone has uh they're big
right these things are advantages in
fighting
in leadership it's the same thing let's
say someone is super articulate
that's helpful let's say someone doesn't
have a bad temper
that's very helpful but everyone is at a
different level well just like you can
take a bunch of different
sized and shaped and athletic ability
people and you can make them better at
fighting
you can take a bunch of people with
different levels of
leadership characteristics and you can
improve them
and then there are actual moves
there's actual moves that you can do as
a leader
that are just like a jiu jitsu move oh
joe comes to me and he's yelling and
screaming at me that
he didn't get the he didn't i didn't
give him two extra people to go on his
job
instead of me going hey joe shut up you
don't know what you're talking about
instead i actually listen to you
right i listen you say well hold on i
didn't know you needed that many people
what do you what do you need them for
so i show a little sense of urgency i
kind of reflect what your
emotions are so i'm not just
creating a fight between you and me
because if you and i are fighting
you and i are not finding a solution so
i'm going to reflect a little bit of
your emotion and then i'm going to
diminish it a little bit so you and i
can have a real conversation
so there's moves that you can do
a leader that function like a jiu jitsu
move
and they're very very powerful and the
more of them you learn the better off
you'll be
and you need to practice them you won't
be good at them
out of the gate it's going to take some
just like if i showed you an armlock and
you've never done jiu jitsu before
you're not going to be able to get on
the mat and do to somebody you're going
to have to try it a couple times you
have to learn the little
nuances to the move so there are ways
that leaders
can get better and yes there's
absolutely
natural leadership qualities that make
people just a natural better leader
but they even those people can improve
so your question of out of a thousand
people how many
really good leaders there are well you
have to ask okay you
just talk about how many people are just
naturally born great leaders
you're probably your suspicion is
correct it's not a huge amount
but how many of those leaders can you
improve exponentially
in their ability to lead and that's what
you don't have a company on front that's
what we do
all the time is we go and work with
companies we work with leaders
that is exactly what we do and we take
companies of i mean we work with
companies that have 150
000 employees and you start getting
everyone all the
all the leaders aligned and getting the
front line troops understanding where
the
where the leadership is and what they're
thinking and
so you can become a much much better
leader
over time now how much of this do we see
in the civilian sector how much do even
more directly how much does this do we
see in the political world
the answer is
an unbelievably small amount i mean
it's a ridiculously small amount yeah
it's a ridiculously small amount
why is that i bet there's a there's a
lot of reasons first of all who
who at this point in in the world
thinks that that sounds like a great job
right hey i'm gonna go
get attacked from all sides i'm gonna
have my personal life picked apart
i'm gonna get you know make i'm gonna
work really hard and
really not i'm gonna have a pay cap on
how much money i make there's all kinds
of reasons why
becoming a politician doesn't look like
the best job
for for most people that would look and
say hey would i rather be the ceo of a
company
and make a ton of money and make create
a huge product and leave a big impact
and influence
thousands of people that work at my
company in a positive way
or would i rather go and get ridiculed
and get broke down and have to try and
get my job again in four years or two
years or whatever the case may be
it's a that's a tough job too and a lot
of people say i'm not gonna
why would i jump into that game well i
know i say that why would i jump into
that game why would i want to go and be
a politician right now
right it's crazy like for me to to for
me to want to go into the
into the political world there would
have to be complete and utter chaos in
america i mean way beyond
beyond where we're at right have you
thought about this yeah i mean i'm
telling you what i think when
because people ask me oh you should do
this you should do that i say um
you know we're not at a point where we
need this we might be about four days
away from we could be
i think the answer you know let's get
let's get uh dwayne the rock johnson
i agree with you he's he's the guy
that could really i think unify people
and i think he would have to run as an
independent i recommend he does it right
now
right right now he should be like yeah
you know what i'm in
i think he would win i think he would
win i really think he would win as an
independent
he's obviously a smart guy he's
super articulate he listens
you can tell that he listens i mean when
you see him interact with people
he's he's very genuine how he interacts
he's built businesses
right he's built big well uh
really uh productive businesses that are
doing great
he he's i think he'd be great he's got a
fantastic work ethic he got a fantastic
work work ethic that he
you know he built he came up from
nothing right he had seven bucks in his
pocket we all know the story
and and he has more bucks in his pocket
than that now
so and most important i think
i think he's just a popular guy you know
he would get up and
and when the country's going through
hard times
you know i was talking to a friend on
the way up here and
they were saying hey you know peop
people
want leadership and they're looking for
it and and they're not hearing it and a
lot of times people don't even recognize
the fact that they don't have leadership
that you don't even recognize it's a
leadership vacuum so they don't even
know
what they should be thinking let me give
an example you're
let's take a seal platoon seal platoon
raids a house
there's some explosions there's some
gunfire and no one's really sure where
it's coming from and no one's really
sure what to do
now that individual a lot of the
individuals in that platoon are just
kind of holding on security they're
holding
they're not really sure what to do and
they're not really even
recognizing that there's a leadership
vacuum but then someone comes in
the leader the platoon chief the platoon
commander comes in and goes
everyone get to the roof right now and
everyone goes oh cool now we know what
to do
so same thing happening in america right
now there's no
kind of voice saying hey everyone
this is what i just saw on this video
this is what i just saw
this was a heinous crime this obviously
we have some deep rooted problems
that we need to fix here's the way i'm
going to move forward
addressing these problems getting to the
bottom of them and here's
how long the timeline is going to be
and by the way my ears are open and you
know where the place you know where i'm
coming right now
i'll be in minneapolis tomorrow
afternoon
that's you know like oh we got a problem
like that if we have a problem like that
i am going on the ground
i will be there i'll be there what i'm
the guys i'm the president
so i'll be there in what two hours i'll
be there on the ground i'm gonna find
out what's going on i'm gonna meet with
people
we're gonna talk i'm gonna listen i'm
gonna find out what this means i'm gonna
get to the bottom of these problems
that's that's what then you can actually
speak from a position of okay i just
spoke to these nine people
matter of fact they're coming with me
we're gonna come up with a plan we're
gonna come up with a plan together
you know that's another huge leadership
everyone thinks in the military that
that the leader's sitting at the top
going all right gentlemen
here's what we're gonna do we're gonna
approach this building from the west
we're gonna assault the front door no
that's not the way it works that's not
the way it should work the way it should
work is
i say to you joe i say hey joe here's
the target i want you to go after
tonight
come up with a plan and you say okay
cool
and then you if you're a good leader you
get with your team and say hey guys
here's the target we're going after how
do you all think we should do it
and now you all come up with your own
plan together
and then you come back to me and say hey
giaco here's how i want to do it and i
said
looks good and maybe if i got to make a
little adjustment i say hey make this
little adjustment here or
maybe use this weapon over here or
whatever i make little tiny adjustments
but it's still your plan
and from a leadership perspective that
means you
are you and your team are totally bought
into the plan
you made it up as opposed to me coming
down and barking orders at you and
telling you how we're gonna do it
doesn't work i mean i can force you to
do it because i outrank you
no i order you to do this that doesn't
that doesn't fly you know how many times
in my entire military career i said hey
i'm the boss
you better do what i tell you to do you
wonder how many times i said that zero
zero times no one thinks like that
so in a leadership position what you
have to do is say
hey i'm gonna come i'm gonna find out
what's going on i'm gonna talk to people
and we're gonna put together a plan to
figure out how we're gonna get this
solved
this is not acceptable in america
that sounds fantastic but what if you're
a republican
and they're democrats and then you get
on the ground and you have a mayor
that's non-compliant you have a governor
that disagrees with your strategy
they don't want you there in the first
place they want to work it out
themselves they want to defund the
police
they're voting unanimously to defund the
police they don't like what you're
saying
cool okay if that's where we're at right
now
let's let's come up with a plan let's
see how we get through this
here's some things i'm worried about
because if you if you're telling me you
want to defund the police because you
think that this
police department is completely and
utterly corrupt
okay let's let's explore that because
you could be right
you could be right this is where a lot
of leaders make a mistake where it
becomes an ego thing
especially like you're talking
republican and democrat so that means if
i'm a republican no democrat can have a
good idea ever
and if i'm a democrat no republican can
have a good idea ever that's completely
wrong
that's completely wrong so even right
now like when you
threaten me right now right now you're
like hey what if i tell you i want to
defend the police and i tell you i don't
want the cops now
you tell me all those things as a good
leader you know what i'm going to say
all right
there must be something really bad going
on here beyond even what i just saw
on this video i'm coming and i want to
hear what's happening
and i want you to tell me what your
suggestions are and if your suggestions
are to defund the police
let's explore where that where that
plays out let's see where that ends up
because as we start peeling back the
layers even the most even the most
ardent anti-police person you're going
to get to a point where you say okay
when my house is when when one of your
constituents house is being broken into
who are they going to call what what
mechanism are we going to put in place
for security
how are we going to keep people safe
from crime
and then they've got to answer that
question and and maybe they come up with
a good answer
i don't know yet but as a leader you
have to listen to other people's ideas
and we have to you you absolutely have
to do that there's a
saying from patton leader on the front
line is always always right
the leader on the front the leader on
the front line is always right
so i've always tried to embrace that
theory not just
from a leadership perspective but even
from a human perspective you know when
you
want to tell me something that i don't
know about
i'm gonna listen to you i'm actually
gonna i'm actually really gonna listen
to you
i'm gonna try and ask myself well let's
see joe lives in this city
and joe's here with this community and
joe is telling me right now
that we should have no police here
well could he be very emotional yes he
could does that mean i should
not listen to anything he says no it
doesn't means i should monitor
your your emotions and i should take
that into account but i should also be
saying
there's got to be some core of truth to
what he's saying
now is it possible that joe's just a bad
actor and just evil
yes it is how do i know that unless i
listen to you
their answer is you don't you know what
i'm hearing right now
jocko and the rock 20 20. that's what
i'm hearing
come on son i think i need you
yeah well um i really hope it doesn't
get to that point saying all makes
fantastic sense but the problem is
everybody is so partisan it's so
difficult to get people to work together
and people are so there's they've so
much invested
in keeping this party divided by these
party lines
keeping the country divided by the the
right and the left it's it's it's
so nuts it's completely nuts it's
completely nuts and when you hear the
extremists on either side you
you should say to yourself you should
say to yourself
they want us to fight right it's like
you know here i'll i'll i'll drop dime
on myself i'm a big
like when i was a kid in the seal teams
i was an instigator
if i could if i could talk smack to two
different people
and let them start to get escalating
like they wanted to fight i would do
that all day long
especially once i started training
people jiu jitsu you know i'd i'd be the
guy that was saying oh he thinks he
could take you now
because he trained for two weeks you
haven't been here and
you said that you know i'll do that all
day long escalate
so we have to do that because it's fun
to watch people fight to the death
that's what i did when i was on fear
factor
it's always instigating people oh it's
fun
yeah there's there's some level of fun
to it yeah but fighting to the death is
this a different kind of fun yeah but
when you
recognize that when people on the
extremes are telling you extreme things
that
what they want is to create a divide
that's what they want so that you just
go you know what i just can't have that
so i'm voting here or i just can't have
this so i'm voting here
it's it's a nightmare it is a nightmare
it's a very difficult one to get out of
you need real leadership to get out of
it
and that's just absent right now on both
sides
totally absent and there's no middle
ground
no no there's no one that says well you
know i
i you know i like some of trump's
policies
right someone says that it's like oh
just destroy that you must be a nuts
yeah or
you know i agree with i agree with
nancy pelosi on this thing you must be
you know a communist
you know either way but that's the way
that's where we're at yeah
that's that's why unfortunately well
fortunately fortunately but
if if the rock was going to run i think
he would only i think he would have to
run
as an independent right to just say
listen i'm not down
there are some things i agree with over
there there's some things i agree with
over there
so you know what i'm doing i'm going in
the middle which is where most of
america
is so if you want to vote extremist you
can go to this side other extreme you go
to this side everyone else vote for me
when was the last time someone even won
as a governor
that was an independent was it jesse
ventura
possibly minnesota yeah possibly it
might have been him
i mean you never even hear about it yeah
well that's there's a whole like money
thing that happens right
there's a whole money thing where if
you're not a republican or a democrat
you're not going to get those big
coffers full of money to put paid
advertising out and
hit get people on the streets to vote
for you yeah you don't have the machine
behind you you don't have the dnc behind
you or the republican party
yeah it's um it's a real weird situation
we find ourselves in with no clear path
to sanity no there's no clear pla
path to sanity if we don't talk to each
other and right now we're not
no we're not i've seen uh
you know the people are so
just angry and just
angry when you talk to him about this
stuff
just anger comes out it's horrible it's
horrible to watch
yeah what what disturbs me is that i
don't
see i mean in the past when there's been
disputes
or things have been wrong it seems like
there's a clear
path to to sort of work things out
it doesn't seem like a clear path it
seems like every day kind of gets a
little worse like people get ramped up
even more
and then there's this event that's
looming on the horizon
this november event this election event
and no matter what whether it's left or
right whether
biden wins or trump wins is going to be
madness and chaos
it seems hard for me to understand that
biden could
it could maintain his health
you know through a presidency that seems
very challenging to me
yeah i mean it seems like he's been
going
down you know with his coherence level
you can kind of see it over even months
right yeah he's on a
really really rapid downward spiral it
seems stressful
for anybody except trump for whatever
[ __ ] reason
that guy eats it up but for most people
running for president alone just the
grueling
just the schedule that's involved in
traveling and doing all these speeches
and
it just breaks them down i mean one of
the reasons why hillary lost
was she just wasn't willing to travel as
much there was all these different
events that she was supposed to go to
she just couldn't go she couldn't take
it anymore she thought she was going to
win anyway so she just stayed
laid back yeah yeah it definitely is a
brutal
thing but it's really also just
completely insane that the two
candidates are these two people
well yeah first of all that the best
that democrats could do
i mean they had all these other people
that were well-spoken
he seemed like young and healthy and
there's you know there's so many that is
hard to comprehend
yeah right extremely it's really hard to
cover that yeah that you're looking at
these
this group of whatever we have 350
million people 320 million people in
america and this is
this is who you end up with yeah i mean
[ __ ] anybody but biden
anybody i mean we don't even know who
his vice president is right that's going
to make a big deal
that's going to be a big difference
because the vice president is compelling
and interesting he says he's going to
pick a woman
whether he picks uh the problem if he
was going to pick klobuchar but kobachar
was responsible
for a lot of those guys skating in
minneapolis so well that's not good
and then if he's going to go with kamala
harris tulsi gabbard kind of took the
legs off of that lady yeah
so then who's left mayor pete he seems
like
a guy who's just you know like he's got
a playbook he's kind of like
following this obama playbook and i just
don't
feel it from him at all at least he's
gay
we'd have a gay guy in office that'd
lighten people up a little bit
i believe that we had a powerful gay
leader i think it'd be great for the
country like i think
you know like the the one of the things
about obama being office beside the fact
being obvious beside the fact that he's
very articulate and educated and just a
well-spoken statesman
is that it's like hey look we're making
progress
we have a black president like i felt
that i felt like a wave across
the country people like you you can be
present in this country like
even if you're born out of a single
family single mother family
and you're a a black guy
you can you as long as you got the goods
you can make it
like this is great this means we really
are living in a meritocracy
and that would be great if there was a
gay guy that had the same experience
like
like all the people that are homophobes
like yeah but that [ __ ] mayor pete
he's got me
he yeah he i i'm not the bible says but
you know what
[ __ ] the bible i'm voting for that guy
he's better than trump
i mean that would be great but he's just
i don't think he's the guy
maybe he's the guy some dave he's also a
young guy right so who else
who the [ __ ] is there especially since
it's gonna be biden
and he said it's gonna be a woman he's
definitely not gonna go with tulsi
she's too [ __ ] dangerous yeah the the
democrats are scared of her she doesn't
play games which is so crazy
i know she's got everything everything
they want woman of color
congresswoman served overseas uh two
deployments yeah
she's got everything she's super
articulate super artistic
she's level-headed super level-headed
very intelligent yeah
but she's just not corrupt she's got
this one problem
that's the one problem i mean other than
that you look at it like jesus christ
this lady
she's willing to talk to people on the
other side
she's you know she's a a states woman
she's a
you know the way she speaks she speaks
like a leader
they won't even consider her she's too
dangerous well so who else is there i'm
going back to
uh dj dwayne the rock johnson yes that's
what i'm saying
independent yeah as an independent yeah
and dwayne and jocko 2020
come on man we need you uh
it's it's very very
it's very horrible and and
when i see all this divide right this is
one thing that
just two
two have been in the military and have
been on the battlefield and
fought alongside guys of every
background
every background that you can imagine
white black
mexican whatever puerto rican asian
they're all everyone's out there
everyone's out there and by the way
going to memorial services for these
guys overseas
there's not one thought in your head
there's not one thought in your head
that's thinking
oh underneath the flag on that coffin is
that a black guy or that a white guy
not one thought in your head is thinking
that in any way shape or form all you
know is that
that person took a bullet got blown up
that could be me they took that for me
and to come back here and and now see
this this
this country being ripped apart
it's that's the most horrible thing for
me
this is something that gets discussed a
lot by guys and teams and
by different guys in the military period
that
when you've served overseas with with
these guys
that racism becomes the the least
the least considered thing it's you
your brothers because you're literally
the consequences of your actions the
consequences
of your day-to-day existence is so so
dire life and death it's the the most
drastic consequences
that we are aware of there's nothing
you're losing your life
or you're not or they save you or they
don't you're brothers you're all
together
but in this world the consequences are
less grave
and the requirements of people
are less extreme you're not as tested
you're not
your character is not as exposed you are
not as
you're not as vulnerable in that sense
and because of that
i think people are more outraged and
they're finding
more reasons why we're separate more
reasons to divide us more reasons why
the they're different from us whether
it's because of ideology or skin color
you know sam harris has a podcast where
he's discussing all the different things
and he brings up one
really great point the podcast that's
out now
he said could you imagine a world where
we
we think of color the same way we think
of
hair color like the color of people's
skin's the same way could you imagine a
world where i don't trust redheads
you know i don't those people with dark
brown hair are [ __ ] creepy to me
you know all the people in my
neighborhood that are blonde they're all
shady
like that seems so preposterous well
one day the goal would be so great
if one day that's how we feel about all
skin color
that it's no different than hair color
it's just characteristics that you were
born with you have no control over who
you
are is what's important that's it yeah
and i think that's
that's what that's the position that the
military
puts you in it puts you in this position
of look i got to rely on this guy
i gotta rely on this guy and if they're
reliable
i'm down i'm good if they're not
reliable i got a problem and it doesn't
matter what color they are
it doesn't matter what their it doesn't
matter any of that it's like is this
person going to be there
is this a good person that's going to be
there to back me up and that's all we
care about
and so for me this is like super
regressive
to be going through this to watch the
country go through this
and think how did wait wasn't i just 10
years ago like
overseas with a bunch of guys and we
didn't care about any of this didn't
didn't didn't enter into our minds
we're not looking at it all the time and
i i guess part of it is because
you gotta you're in a fight you're in a
struggle
and and right now let's face it in
america
there's not a lot of struggling
happening right we're kind of making our
own struggle right now
exactly yeah and i think one of the
things you've talked about that's very
important
is that a lot of this divide is because
of this really shitty way of
communicating whether it's through
social media
or whether it's through reading stories
or watching videos it's a terrible way
to not just get in for
information but it's a terrible way to
interact with people like the way to
interact with people is the way you and
i are doing it right now
just talking to people and i think the
vast majority of problems
would be solved amongst reasonable
people if they just talked through
they just talked to try to figure out
you know you know hey man i didn't like
that you did this
well what did i well all right well i
was thinking when i did this here's what
you're right
here's why i did it and this is what i
was thinking and i was wrong because of
that
and if people could just say that and
people could accept that and people
could shake hands or
hug it out rather than have a [ __ ]
twitter beef that leads to a gunfight
i mean literally that's the the way we
exchange information with each other
back and forth through social media is
the absolute worst way people can talk
you're not looking at each other you
don't get any social cues
you don't feel any empathy towards that
person you're not in front of them
you're not there
and you're looking to see how many
people agree or disagree who's liking or
dis because it's a public thing right
so how many likes do they get their
thing got 400 likes mine only got 20.
[ __ ] am i wrong here it's
it's just a terrible way for us
it's it's a newfound way for us to
communicate and a terrible way for us to
communicate
it's not we're not designed for it this
is not how we evolved
we evolved to communicate with social
cues and to look at each other
and be around each other and you know
you could say something
to a person and uh you you you're both
laughing
or you see it written down the same way
and you're like that guy's a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
yeah even from a leadership perspective
you know we'll talk about this a lot
with
hey you know i sent you i'll send you an
email you know that says
hey joe can you get this project done
next week
thanks and you're in a bad mood when you
read that
you know you're go who the hell do you
think you're telling but if i was like
hey joe
can you get this project done by next
week we really need it i'm looking at
you and
kind of give me a blank stare and i
explain it to you a little bit more and
all of a sudden it turns into a
perfectly good conversation
exactly when i send you that email or in
this case a tweet
right then you you hate me yeah it's
like we got
management to do right yeah you gotta
you
when you want something out of someone
or you want you want some things to get
done
you gotta manage that person's
personality and mood and
you gotta manage the relationship that
you have with each other and you have to
be
proactive you have to you have to call
what's up man how you doing everything
good
you're good like they have to get a good
feeling out of you yeah and they're
going to say listen
i gotta ask you this favor i need this
thing from you and then and then you're
rolling
and everything's good exactly if you
don't do it that way
then people go [ __ ] this guy oh this guy
just wants things from me or
this guy's annoying or you know th these
guys treat me like a [ __ ]
exactly yeah the uh world through zoom
right now
so we're doing a lot of zooming so my
company has long front
the just the video alone increases your
ability to communicate
right massively it doesn't get all the
way there
right but just being able to look at
someone and have a conversation with
them as opposed to
either just a hearing on the phone or
absolutely so so that idea of hey i'm
actually going to sit down and talk to
you
i'm actually going to sit down hey i'll
meet you the r like
we pivoted obviously once you know we
used to go into
or we still do but going into businesses
and working with them
shaking hands how you doing talking to
them and then all of a sudden in three
days we were doing everything online
everything hey just meet me on this zoom
call and you can get there you can get
97
effectiveness just by looking at someone
and talking to them you know
like i said there's a little percentage
that you're still not going to get but
if you think you're going to communicate
effectively through
social media tweets you're just freaking
wrong
yeah that's one step below email right
yeah social media tweets is one step
below
email email's one step above that phone
calls is one step above that
zoom is a step above that another layer
person to person is the best first
person that's what we're designed for
everything else is just it's and and
that's what's leading to all this
[ __ ] madness and chaos
a lot of it is fueled it's weaponized by
by social media tweets and yeah because
by the way when you
send me a tweet to be to be an [ __ ]
to me
i i actually just retweet that and tell
everyone what an [ __ ] you are a bunch
of people retweeted as well
look at mayhem oh god we're not we're
not working together
we're not we don't we're not working
together right that's another thing that
kovit did right all of a sudden we took
everyone and isolated them you're not
you're not seeing them you're not
talking to them so now everyone is
almost strictly communicating by these
methods that you're talking about yeah
this is horrible
horrible for society horrible for
society
the uh the idea of coming to work in a
place
right the idea of hey i'm gonna show up
and work at a place with other people
that is such a huge part of
getting back to where we need to be like
when you pull everyone out of work and
you and there and
and even worse and i'm not even just
beyond covid
you know what happens we've moved all
manufacturing overseas right so all
those people that used to go and work in
the same place every day
that used to show up and have a common
mission and a common goal
they don't have that anymore much of the
middle class doesn't have that anymore
they used to have it they don't have it
anymore
and that's interestingly
china's middle class is growing right
now why is their middle class growing
because they're manufacturing they're
making things they're filling that void
of people that have that level of skill
set of hey
you know what i just got out of high
school i can't afford college so what am
i going to do
right oh well in china well you can say
okay well i guess i'm going to work at a
factory hey it's a horrible sweatshot
it's
do whatever we need that they need to
improve their
their conditions but hey these people
have a job they have a purpose they're
moving in a certain direction
in america we've kind of on a massive
scale
gotten rid of that class of people's
purpose and that's a big focus for you
right
with your company origin in particular
yeah which uh by the way i got the boots
they're [ __ ] dope
you guys make great [ __ ] it's like
really high quality
really beautifully manufactured stuff
like and
there's something very valuable right
now about american-made it used to be
this it was very divisive like you said
american made like what are you
xenophobic you don't like foreigners
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
but now you realize like oh well with
covid
you know we were cut off from even
getting goods and supplies from other
countries
and then we were getting so much of our
medical supplies from china
and then we're getting so much of our
vaccines and medicine all these
different things
manufactured by china you're like hey
why don't we do that here well we used
to but
i was cheaper buy like a dollar a thing
to send it over there like oh christ and
people are realizing now there's a
there's a great benefit
to making things here in america and
it's not just
this idea of national pride national
pride's great
but also like you don't you don't have
to go anywhere to get things and
you keep jobs here yeah and i think uh
kanye west
is looking to build same same thing as
we're doing he wants to manufacture
stuff
in america why because he knows when you
have a bunch of
underprivileged kids the best thing you
can provide a bunch of underprivileged
kids
is jobs jobs that they can entry-level
jobs i know when i was a kid
it was almost like hey if you're not
careful you're gonna end up working in
the factory
right that's what's gonna you know you
can end up working in a factory no one
wanted a factory job
the thing is so so that kind of became a
mantra oh you don't want to work in a
factory you better go to college
well there's first of all factory work
has changed
there's jobs that people do in a factory
that takes a massive skill set
and the boots you know the origin boots
we were probably a year two years three
years from
losing the knowledge of how to actually
do that
and luckily my buddy pete has started
you know
grabbing people that know how to do it
and passing that information down to the
next generation
so we can actually be a self-sufficient
country
and we can bring back those jobs of
people that
look that's a that's a proud way to make
a living
these are craftsmen like you said these
are craftsmen and crafts women by the
way
our factory is mostly filled with women
and they're out there they have a skill
set
they're learning a skill set there's
there's upward mobility
as you get better at your job as you can
do more things you can make more money
and by the way
you're making something you're making
something
with your hands you're producing
something here in this country
that's just like well it's like when you
go hunting when i go hunting
you get something for yourself there's a
certain feeling
of being self-sufficient and america on
a large scale
especially during covid we look up and
say wait a second we can't even
we can't even make that stuff we don't
even know how to make that
that's a nightmare well the boots in
particular think think about if you
started
from scratch like if i started from
scratch i don't know [ __ ] about how to
make a boot
if i had a it would take a long learning
curve of figuring out how to make an
excellent boot that fits right
is well made and durable like those
boots that you guys sell
like i was going over i was looking at
this thing i'm like they [ __ ] put
some time and effort into this thing
like this is a really well crafted piece
of art
i mean it's it's it's functional artwork
and that knowledge because that's not
that's not that's not our generation i
learned that right we're
we're pulling that information from the
old shoe dogs
up in maine that are 60 years old 70
years almost you know out of the
workforce having to bring them back into
the workforce
to to educate the younger generation
on how to actually do this we got a kid
up there his name is cameron
oh he's 22 20 a young kid and he
has learned now how to weave the
material for our geese
so he's the guy that knows how to weave
material
this is the bro this is so complicated
where do you see all these different
pieces of string coming together get
this big machine with so he's got like a
loom
yeah he's got we've got looms up there
but we had to get the knowledge
right from the old timers that said okay
let me show you how to do this and like
you just said
how long would it take to figure out a
loom on your own first of all i think i
would fail because i don't think i'd
have the patience if i just had this
machine
to look at so capturing this knowledge
so that we can become a self-sufficient
country again
it's got to be paramount in what we're
doing and it's not
just it's not just hey because i'm
pro-america
yes i am but if if we want to get rid of
the kind of social unrest that we have
right now
hey in ramadi you got a 15 year old kid
that's putting a roadside bomb
in the road you know why he's doing that
is he doing it for some big ideology
no he's not he's doing it because he's
going to get paid 50 by the insurgents
he wants a job he wants a life
he wants to make money what happens in
america
what happens with kids in the inner city
that are
underprivileged when they don't have a
job what are they going to do
what are they going to do they're going
to fall into oh maybe i'll sell drugs
maybe i'll commit robberies whatever i'm
going to do
but they're not doing it by choice in
many cases or if they're doing it by
choice it's because they don't see any
other
choices to even make so we've let our
manufacturing go away
and now we've got voids we've got
voids where people don't have an ability
to make an income
and that's that's that's that's just a
complete
loss of pride right if you don't have
the ability to earn money to take care
of yourself to take care of your family
if you don't have that ability what are
you going to do you're going to figure
out how to make it happen
it's so short-sighted too i mean it was
all done for
just a small amount of profit per item
small amount of profit per item and it
it cost
the country so much yeah and and and
then the
then the narrative became we're not able
to do it
that's why we don't do it we're not able
to do it that became the narrative well
you know
even the big corporations would say well
you know we'd love to we'd love to make
stuff here but it's impossible
it's impossible well that's ridiculous
completely and totally ridiculous it's
also like
you when you go through detroit and you
realize that detroit at one point in
time
in the early 20th century was one of the
richest countries in the world
or excuse me one of the richest cities
in the world you you go through it you
realize okay this is where they're
making all the [ __ ] badass cars
all the amazing american cars of the 60s
and the 70s they were all made right
there
and then they [ __ ] up someone made
some decisions to save a little bit of
money and make a little bit of money
and completely short-sighted didn't look
at the economy as a whole
didn't look at the nation from a
position of a patriot someone who
looks at the country in the whole what's
best for the country they just said what
is the best way
that we can maximize our profit well we
we need to
set up factories in mexico and china and
all all these other places we can get
people to work for nothing
you can't buy a [ __ ] cell phone
that's made in america
all the people that design and engineer
cell phones for apple
they're right here they're not making
them here there's not a [ __ ]
single cell phone that's made in america
try buying one that's made with
all american parts all american labor in
america
what no such thing it doesn't exist and
what you're going to be told is
it can't be done that's whole language
cannot be done that's what's cool about
elon musk
oh watch this yeah exactly i'll make
cars here i'll make them awesome
i'll make rocket ships whatever that
guy's
[ __ ] tunnels under the earth yeah we
need a couple more of those dudes
yeah it's uh it's it's good that people
are opening their eyes though
it's good that people are realizing
because of the pandemic and because the
fact that all
goods and services that were being
imported on a daily basis were shut down
and also people are terrified of getting
things over there what are you gonna
spray everything down and everything's
infected and what do you what i'm scared
what do i do
yeah but the medicine is the craziest
one the fact that we rely on china for
some ungodly percentage of all of our
medicine like holy [ __ ] guys
like is this the right way to do this
just for profit yeah
it's it seems like we got a little bit
lucky with covid yes like right a little
bit lucky because it turned out to be
not
not bad did you ever get the antibody
test no
[ __ ] i should have tested you today
sorry because you think you might have
had it right
i'm so
the end of january right right as this
thing was kicking off i did a
live tour i did austin
then i did washington dc then i did
new york city seattle san francisco
and l.a every event shook hands and bro
hugged between a thousand and two
thousand
people that's what i did at the end of
january
i went to the the absolute like ground
zero locations for kovid
and just just bro hugged and talked to a
bunch of people and shook hands and
you know just got after it and then i
got sick
uh yeah like a week later something two
weeks later i guess it was
february i was sick and i was like
gee i wonder what that is and then and
then march came around and we started
the the the sick like it wasn't real bad
it wasn't real bad but it was it was you
know it was bad enough that uh you know
i i think i might have skipped like
i'm just gonna stretch today because i
really feel like crap for a workout type
of thing
so i didn't get i wasn't down hard i
wasn't you know i didn't miss any i
didn't miss anything
but i felt bad and so i figured that was
my that was my coveted experience
my wife got sick my son got sick two
daughters in college and my young
daughter
didn't get sick at all my ten-year-old
daughter didn't get sick at all so
that sounds like it yeah but yeah did
you have it or not no i didn't i'm
making a [ __ ] text right now
i'm gonna get a doctor in here in an
hour and a half when we're done
i'm gonna i'm gonna make this happen
because i want to find out
you would be the only guy that's tested
positive if you did no we had
uh tim's buddy what's his name ben
he didn't false positive then we tested
him again
yeah i think it would be i think it
would be crazy if
that travel schedule that i had sitting
on all those airplanes from and to and
from all those different airports in all
those airports
that's just that's just crazy yeah all
right i'm asking right now can we get
one at 3 30.
i'm gonna make it happen that was
another you know we're talking about
egos
the the the scary thing about the whole
covid
unraveling was that
the leadership wouldn't say hey you know
what i actually think i was wrong about
this and we're moving in this direction
now
right not just leadership but everyone
right everyone just
hey no you know what i think i was wrong
here but maybe we need to adjust this
here's so you didn't get to see that
that's a great point because that that
really was a failure of leadership
because it was very clear at some point
in time when they found out
when they did the large-scale antibodies
test particularly in california and they
were like jesus christ
hundreds of thousands of people have
been exposed to this
this is not what we thought like and the
amount of people that are actually sick
instant result back um
you're dead the the amount of people
that um
that actually tested positive for the
antibodies was way higher than they
thought it was
and the amount of people that were
actually hospitalized was way lower
and then they looked at the average debt
that people died it's actually older
than the average debt that people died
yeah yeah my son pointed that out to me
yeah we shut down the [ __ ] economy
for that
yeah i i guess i was was a little bit
whatever i was pretty i was pretty
cavalier through the whole thing our
buddy dr pete yeah
he he was he was a little nervous well
he was way nervous because he was in
early right and when you saw the early
stuff
when you're like hey it's one out of
every 10 people are dying right
but even he was making adjustments he
said wait a second in italy there's
different cities that was i think where
he started changing his his attitude he
said wait a second in italy there's
different cities
and in some cities they're really
compressed together and people are old
people living with young people in the
same place and
oh wait a second we need to separate
this out and then it just
hey it wasn't as bad thank god yeah
thank god it wasn't as bad and
uh my buddy andrew schultz had a great
point he said basically covet exposed
weaknesses in both business and in
people's health
that's what it really did the the the
lockdown did
because there was businesses that
literally couldn't survive a week
without money coming in
well that's a that's a badly managed
business or a business
that has a very small and narrow profit
margin and then there's people
that literally can't survive any sort of
disruption in their immune system
their immune system is shattered one of
the things that came out of it that i
found out from dr rhonda patrick was
that
70 percent of america is deficient in
vitamin d
70 29 is severely deficient to the point
where like
they're they're like they have medical
issues because of a deficiency in
vitamin d
yeah you got to get on that you got to
get on the vitamin d for that to get on
the vitamin d and the best way to get it
is to get out in the sun
yeah and that's the one thing you
weren't supposed to do the whole thing
is [ __ ] madness
it was a perfect storm yeah it's like
when the plague
in the black plague they thought it was
they thought it was cats they thought
cats delivered the plague to everyone so
they killed all the cats but it wasn't
the cats it was the rats and the mice
and so when you killed the cats guess
what happened to the rats and the mice
they
went insane so almost the same kind of
thing
you see unfolding yeah and no one's
saying hey you know what actually
we're wrong here hey you know what and
what about the masks so this was crazy
well i got some buddies that texted me
they said hey there's this thing coming
you origin you guys should start making
masks
just to just to cover your face and i
said oh okay i don't know anything about
this stuff
i talked to my buddy pete i said hey it
sounds like that we're gonna need to
make masks
and he says okay so we we start thinking
about hey how would we make these things
and then a couple days later the
government the government
comes out and says mass don't do
anything don't worry don't wear mass
don't get masks so i talked to peter
said hey man
it looks like this isn't good it looks
like we don't need to do it because it
looks like it doesn't help at all
five days later they're like everyone
wear a mask
at all times and by the way we're gonna
pass laws
that require you to wear a mask i'd call
pete i'm like it looks like we need to
make masks
you know and we ended up making 100
a couple hundred thousand masks and we
were
we were sending them to this is the
weird thing we're sending them to
hospitals like we donated thousands of
mass to hospitals
and and and then you know two weeks
later it was like no actually they don't
do anything
i still don't know well it's hard
the problem is people get shamed and the
the world health organization came out
and basically said the only reason you
should be wearing a mat where's the cdc
now the world here fauci said us
government held off promoting face masks
because it knew shortages were so bad
that even doctors couldn't get enough
so is he just saying that now this
morning or today
since we started so guess what you all
every we all
got lied to we all got lied to
held off on promoting face masks because
it knew shortages were so bad but even
doctors couldn't get enough
recently the cdc said the only people
that should be wearing
masks are people that are treating covet
patients
and that regular people shouldn't be
wearing masks and then the world health
organization said that
asymptomatic people it's extremely rare
that they transmit to other people
so we were worried about asymptomatic
people which is the reason why we kept
kids out of school
and we were worried about overwhelming
hospitals which is why we did all this
other stuff as well
which is what drove me crazy about my
kids school i was like hey
you [ __ ] this doesn't even kill the
kids it's killing
the kids get killed by the flu meanwhile
you don't even scan the teachers or
the staff or anybody people have the flu
they don't want to miss a day of work
they just [ __ ] show up and give it to
everybody
that's normal and kids actually die from
the flu
and it's not a small number it's not a
small number of people that die from the
flu
last year was 62 000 i mean it's not as
many as covid but then you're hearing
you're hearing two camps you're hearing
one the the covet deaths are actually
under reported because a lot of people
die from covet and they don't even
register it
okay boy i guess it's worse than it is
and then you're hearing no no
actually we're getting incentivized to
report deaths as
kovit elon musk on the podcast said if
you got killed by a shark
but you were covid positive they were
listed as a coveted
obviously he was being facetious but not
entirely
because there's a lot of people with
leukemia that also had covet
listed as a covet death obesity heart
attacks
listed as a covid death because they
tested positive for covid
cancer also had kovid covet death yeah i
mean
[ __ ] that's really disturbing you know
when you hear those statistics
then you see these things that they're
saying and just the lack of trust that
you end up with the government exactly
when the government is already
people just generally don't really trust
the government a lot
right right there's no one that's always
thinking the government has always
giving him the straight skinny and it
goes back to this click baity [ __ ]
my wife pointed out this story
yesterday where she's reading about this
kid that died 17 year old kid
perfectly healthy it says she reads into
the article
type 1 diabetes type 1 diabetes is not
perfectly healthy
no that's really sick and [ __ ]
dangerous and you have to take insulin
to stay alive
yeah and think you can get complications
from diet like oh
everyone's living type 1 diabetes
diabetics can live real normally and
then they can have an
instance that causes them to die yeah
they can have their foot removed
yeah there's all sorts of [ __ ] that goes
wrong when you have diabetes your immune
system is severely compromised
but it's like we're our information
it's not pure we're getting all this
muddy thing and
fauci telling us the only reason why
they told us not to wear masks is
because
they knew you didn't have enough like
holy [ __ ] how many people died because
of that you [ __ ]
and then the world health organization
says actually no one died because of
that
you don't have to worry about it you
really don't need to wear a mask
like [ __ ] what is happening the i
think
so much of this ego plays so much into
this of people might want to admit
they're wrong
here's another thing that people won't
say i don't know
right i don't know like as a leader i've
been in situations where i did not know
this is how i tell leaders all the time
i say listen tell your people the truth
about what's happening
by the way we're seeing examples where
this is factually not happening inside
america right now
if you're a leader tell the people the
truth about what's going on that's what
you need to do
and then people come back to me and they
say well what if
what if i don't know what what if i
don't know the truth then what you do is
you say hey
i don't know the truth hey guys i don't
know i don't know exactly how this is
going to play out
these are some contingencies that i'm
preparing for that is
so much more acceptable from the troops
than when you try and pretend like you
know what you're talking about it turns
out you're wrong right
i mean trump does this so much that
people lose track of it right where
he thinks something and he just goes out
on a limb he just walks
right out on a limb and says hey this
cove itself will be gone in a week
yeah and and you know then he just saws
off the limb behind his foot
he does that all the time it's it's a
good example of how not to lead because
then people start to trust you less and
less and then when things like this
happen where you find out
that they actually did purposely now
think if they would have said this
like oh we're worried about we don't
have enough masks then you know what you
come out and say
you come on you say listen everyone
we're not a hundred percent sure
what the masks do for people but we do
know this
inside of a medical environment we have
to prioritize getting those people that
are absolutely exposed
these masks that is why we are going to
put
some kind of a control over who's
allowed to buy them
you just tell the truth well that was
kind of happening at some places like
amazon was only doing that they weren't
the only selling those what is it n95
yeah they were selling them only to
hospital workers and there you go
they were allocating them along with uh
other types of
hand sanitizer and a bunch of different
things they were selling specifically to
them first and first responders
perfect example yeah what you don't do
is say
hey everyone don't worry about it right
right
but if him if he's saying that like well
hey [ __ ] oh
now we can't trust you ever again
exactly yeah
that's that's the freaking problem
you're looking at this guy
next time there's some kind of disease
next time there's a problem how do we
know if we can listen to you
there's also a thing he was saying a
couple of weeks ago the united states
doesn't open up soon
we could we could face permanent damage
like oh economic damage yeah permanent
economy you think
yeah and i'm like hey hey hey hey how
come you didn't say this before
how come you didn't say hey we have to
weigh in the pros and the cons here
yeah you know you you should have and
this is actually something i
uh i talked to peter t about it i said
hey
it seems like maybe some people should
be quarantined
and other people shouldn't and he's like
yeah absolutely
so like my dad who's an older guy who's
you know he's an older guy compromised
immune system guess what he should be
isolated he should be quarantined should
my
17 year old son should my 20 year old
daughter my 21
20 18 year old my 10 year old should
they be in isolation
should they be quarantined absolutely
not absolutely not hey
first week two weeks where we're hearing
it's a ten percent bother you we're
hearing all these things cool
you can make a you can make an
in-extremis call you can say hey guys i
don't know what's happening but in italy
it looks real bad
guess what we're gonna do we're gonna
shut down for two weeks i'm sorry but
this is what we're gonna do
and you go the nation says ah okay
okay we get it and then two weeks later
you say you know what
it looks like it's it really might
impact our medical systems we're gonna
shut down for another
two weeks just another two weeks
everyone goes
you know i gotta pay my mortgage but
okay two more weeks
and then you say then you gotta then you
gotta have the courage and
the ability to put your ego in check and
say you know what thank you
maybe may not have been necessary we
don't know right now but it looks like
we can start opening back up let's rock
and roll
the other problem is once they tell you
what to do they don't want to stop
having that power and control oh yeah
our governor literally said wear masks
because then we can get back some of our
freedoms
yeah you're gonna give away freedom you
got that kind of power
maybe i should run for governor yeah i
didn't know i could just control
freedoms you got my vote
give away freedoms the the
business is surviving right you're
talking about the businesses surviving
there's a lot of businesses that
especially
little businesses right little jiu jitsu
schools little restaurants
you want a restaurant to operate on 50
capacity
that you restaurants aren't making this
kind of money where they can throw away
50 of their profits 50 of their
capability to make money
they still because they still got to
have that cook yeah that cook is there
the dishwasher's there right
there's your bare minimum yeah and they
got to be there no matter what if you
serve 50 people great if you only serve
25 you don't make any money
yeah so there's all there's going to be
there's a lot of businesses
that run that day-to-day you know
month-to-month
paycheck to paycheck to try and stay
afloat that's the that's what america
does
and sometimes they're able to creep out
of that and they get ahead and that's
awesome that's how you end up with these
big powerful companies
yeah i've had a couple of restaurant
owners in uh adam perry lang who owns
apl steakhouse and uh janet zuccarino
and evan funke who
own um they own uh feli well he she owns
felix janet owns felix and uh
he's the head chef and they were
explaining to me profit margins
and uh it's [ __ ] crazy it's it's when
you you
really look at how difficult it is to
run
a restaurant and all the decisions that
have to be made and you know food goes
bad if you keep it too long and you
gotta buy
a certain amount of food you anticipate
a certain amount of customers you gotta
know your customer he was explaining you
gotta you we we know our customers so
i know most of them are not gonna order
this so i'm gonna have certain amount of
meals
that i'm gonna have of the fish and more
meals of the steak and the pasta's
primary
that's what most people are coming here
for and like [ __ ] and then you tell them
oh you can only open up at 60 percent
and waitresses have to wear a [ __ ]
hazmat suit
and you know it's like god damn man what
are they 10
15 5 profit margin i think they were
saying
14 is how they operate
um but it's difficult it's very
difficult and you know people don't want
to
spend too much money on meals you know
and so they
it has to be kind of engineer like how
how how can you
how can you do it right and janet has
had a ton of successful restaurants like
she's a wizard at it i mean she's been
doing it
straight out of college and her problem
was she was
in the process of building multiple
restaurants so all of her money
were out even though she's extremely
profitable and
very very successful at all these
restaurants she's building out all these
other restaurants
at the same time with that money because
she knows how to make money
she knows how to run these businesses so
she's doing it so she's got a jamaican
restaurant she's got
an italian restaurant she's got all
these things happening and then
boom the government tells you you have
to shut down
that's yeah that's uh the the profit
margin
so there's so many bits you know because
we work with all kinds of different
businesses yeah
and the profit margin on many many
businesses
is really really lean one of my favorite
examples
is big construction companies the big
construction companies that are doing
you know 500 million dollar projects or
you know 700 million dollar bridges and
coliseums and stuff
their profit margin is like four percent
holy
it's like six percent that is so insane
and they're
you know ordering concrete and they've
got to have it show it up a certain time
and then the rebar wasn't in place
like it's crazy there the margin for
error is so small
and there's so many businesses that
operate like that
and a lot of times i think some of the
people in government they've never been
in business before
right and so they don't understand that
for them
hey just operate at 50 capacity inside
your restaurant you'll be fine
that's a very good point and they've
never run a business you know i have a
jiu jitsu gym
we got shut down so now now we're now
they're telling us
hey you can allow people back in the gym
they just have to be six feet apart
we can't do jiu jitsu six feet apart you
can't do muay thai six feet apart
so what are we supposed to do now and by
the way
what about oh you want us to check
people and we want to have this there's
all these protocols that are putting in
place to have someone come into the gym
so now we gotta hire extra people we
gotta hire extra cleaning staff
because the gym has to shut down for
this period of a day and they need to
re-clean everything like obviously the
people that are
making these rules have never been in it
never been in business before
yeah telling a person who is
running a jiu jitsu gym the people have
to be six feet apart
the jiu jitsu is zero apart zero feet
apart
zero zero space that's the whole goal of
jiu-jitsu yes it is smash
it's the whole goal take your body and
smash someone's body with it
the whole idea is no space yeah that
literally is the foundation of jiu-jitsu
a pressure applied with no space
and this goes back to the idea of as a
leader
taking the information from the
frontline troops
and saying how you tell me what's a good
way to run this
you tell me you tell me what's a good
way to run this and let's see if we can
figure out a solution
i would really want to talk to jiu jitsu
gym owners
and my suggestion i've never run a jiu
jitsu gym i've been in a shitload of
them
my suggestion would be have people fill
out a waiver
so they waive their rights have people
fill out a form that says i have not
tested positive i've showed
no symptoms of illness i i promise that
if i do
i will not train and i will get myself
tested testing is readily
available now you know for a long time
we were getting shamed because we were
testing people yeah i was i was tracking
angry that we were testing people like
look you can test people too you [ __ ]
just like you could buy a steak it just
costs money
you know are you mad that people have
steak and you can't afford a steak well
you know there's people that they're
different stages of life
you know in this game called society and
capitalism and an advance you start off
at square a
you know everybody starts at a different
spot granted but i started at the bottom
and you figure out a way to get a
[ __ ] task
and if you're in a spot right now in
your life where you can't have a test
well definitely don't go and expose
yourself until we know what the [ __ ] it
is but don't get mad if people can
afford tasks you crazy [ __ ]
yeah and what we're at right now with
jiu jitsu gyms is you should have
a form that you fill out just like when
i was at a restaurant i went to the
lonesome dove restaurant shout out to
them in austin texas
fantastic place they make you fill out a
little form it says uh
you haven't been tested positive you
know you don't you're not sick
you're not showing any symptoms you know
they do a little temperature check check
your forehead oh you're looking good all
right come on in
sit down did they pack you in or to keep
you no they could be a little bit
separated but
that was two weeks ago and uh there's
another place uh gus's fried chicken
shout out to gus's best [ __ ] fried
chicken on earth in austin texas
we went there two weeks ago and you
couldn't eat there
you had to wear a mask in the restaurant
and you had to order take
out so we got take out then we came back
again yesterday
yesterday no [ __ ] mask everybody's in
there sitting all the seats are packed
they strongly suggest you wear a mask
and no one's listening no one wore a
[ __ ] mask the waiters aren't wore
masks
but it's like things are getting
different there's another restaurant red
ash that we
we ate at uh saturday night that place
uh
had 75 capacity and you had to wear a
mask
until you got to your table and then you
had to wear a mask again if you had to
go take a leak you got to put your mask
back on take a leak come back
and it doesn't make any sense it's like
they're just there's health department
guidelines and people they're trying to
open up and they don't want to get sued
they don't want to get people mad and
like
we're we're trying to protect everybody
but we don't know how to do it
and it doesn't matter what the science
of you you could show them an article
that shows that masks are [ __ ]
and they're still going to tell you but
you're still going to wear your mask
because we're playing a little game here
we're playing a game called keep people
safe nobody's saying a goddamn thing
about take your vitamins drink water
stay healthy work out get out in the sun
no no the government never says that you
don't hear
governor knew someone is [ __ ] goofy
slick back hair he's not telling you to
go work out and get in the sun
it's going to be a i think america can
only take so much and i kind of said
this from the beginning
like you can keep america in lockdown
for a little while two weeks
four weeks and then people start saying
you know what i gotta go out i gotta go
make something happen
i gotta do something i gotta earn money
and it's the people that are looking
around saying uh well
i don't really need to earn anybody
right now they're the ones that are
saying everyone stay in your house and
don't come out and wear a mask
all right we got a doctor coming at 3
30. no i told him i think i got you a
positive
this time he's wanting to get a positive
he's like oh he hasn't got anything
goddamn healthy people in here yeah i've
had um
now i've had i think i've had seven no
eight tests
one two three four nose swabs
i've had four yeah four nose swabs and
four antibody tests i haven't
me personally i've still come out
negative every time
but the other thing that he said and
this doctor's a very smart guy
and a young healthy guy he said that
doesn't mean you haven't been exposed to
it it means your immune system did its
job
really there's another thing that people
are saying people saying oh well you
just got lucky you haven't been around
somebody who had it it was no no
many of the people that i tested are
positive are in a family where the other
people
that are also in that family are
negative so they have it they've been
around these people for [ __ ] weeks
and they don't get it why because they
have a better immune system particularly
children so i guess i'm in a win-win
situation yeah because
if i had it if i tested positive it was
like see no factor
it powered through it you beat it now
even if i didn't have it i'm gonna say
hey see
i beat it yeah i'm gonna win win yeah
i know well depending upon
what your results are i know nine people
that have had it now
and out of those people only one of them
had it bad and that was my friend
michael yo
and he got it bad from if it's real easy
to track
he flew all the way to new york no sleep
what was the date he was in january
january
jamie no early february or late january
march march the show in new york was
marked very beginning
so end of february end of february he
was here
and then he went okay so he left here
that weekend went to new york no sleep
right flask in new york does radio does
tv also
does his comedy gigs no sleep does gigs
the next day same deal
does promo all this [ __ ] flies back home
no sleep
gets up in the morning drives to vegas
with his wife and kids
the [ __ ] kid screaming in the car
drives back home that night
hangs out with his wife's family in
vegas and drives back on that so eight
hours in the car just that day
then the next day he's got auditions day
after that he's got auditions and then
boom
hits the wall and he's [ __ ] and he
feels like [ __ ] yeah and he felt like
[ __ ]
by the way his mom got it she also
tested positive beat it in a day
how long was he down for he was down for
a week but he ran himself to also
vitamin d
deficient and so all those things ran
himself down
vitamin d deficient doesn't take care of
himself
so like but but he caught the perfect
storm of exhaustion and travel
travel [ __ ] you up it [ __ ] you up
yeah and i uh leading into this i was
trying i've been traveling all the time
my whole life matter of fact
the lockdown is the law most consecutive
nights i've ever spent with my wife
since we've been married and we've been
married for 20 years
most consecutive nights because you know
i was in the navy i was deploying i was
going on trips and then
when i retired i was working with
consulting all over the place it's not
amazing yeah so it's been kind of cool
hanging out with my wife night after
night
all right these are fda approved kits
too so we're good
so we're totally good we're going to
find out for real fully legit
doctors pumped what do you think do you
think i you think i've had it or not
what do you think
yeah i would say because your kid your
youngest kid didn't
get it get sick and then the other
people did get sick but no one got it
badly
and i know your family's very healthy i
know your your daughter's a savage your
son's a savage
i would imagine you probably had it
thinking about all the places you've
been i bet you
i bet you test positive for the
antibodies i know a few jiu jitsu guys
have got it
but they all just got coughs yeah oh
yeah plus plus on top of all this i'm in
my gym
you know i was in my gym oh yeah you
know we got all kinds and we we have a
lot of people that show up at my gym
because they just want to train they
want to come check it out yeah and my
gym is big you know we've got
2 000 members right yeah it's 2 000
members because it's not just
victory mma and fitness in san diego
california but
you know so it's a big gym yeah and you
know every
thousand members that means they're all
interacting with you know three or four
other people
outside of the gym if not five or ten
people so and they're literally sweating
in each other's mouth
completely oh yeah that's another thing
that's another indicator when i got sick
my main training partner this guy andy
andy burke
i trained with all the time he got sick
and then his girlfriend got sick
he was also a jiu jitsu fighter uh mma
fighter
she got sick too so yeah
we'll see i'm curious it's hard when you
train hard you get sick
it's part part of the the thing too when
you break down your body and your your
immune system gets
you know when you're one of those guys
that trains really hard you do have a
tendency to get little colds
because your immune system gets tested
here's something i've noticed when i
have
downtime like let's say this has
happened to me a few times i'm going to
montana
and i'm i'm super stoked i'm going to go
up there and
chill right as soon as i get up there i
get sick
really it's happened to me like maybe
three times where i
i finally have four days or five days
where i
you know don't have anything scheduled
to go up there i'm gonna shoot my bow
i'm gonna chill
and i get up there and it's like my mind
switches and all of a sudden i
get sick it's like i saved up illness
to where i know i can be allowed to get
sick
does that ever happen to you no but
there's a good argument there
for like just the way your mind controls
your whole system
yeah because your mind is just like
pedaled through the [ __ ] metal slayer
in the background
yeah everything is go go go and then
when it's silence your body's like [ __ ]
what have we been up to
i feel like that happens i was wondering
if it ever happened to you because
it's it's it's happened enough time that
i'm talking about it right
my best example is cam haynes that
[ __ ] is never sick
and if he's sick he still runs anyway
he's just got like a little bit of a
cough
but out of all the people that i know i
don't know anybody who
who's consistently putting in the kind
of hours every day that he does
oh yeah he runs 16 miles every [ __ ]
day yeah
sometimes a marathon sometimes a
marathon every day while he works eight
hours a day
and then he gets home and lifts weights
i mean it's not like he runs
and he gets his reps in he gets his reps
in with his bow every day
and he's lifting and he's lifting every
day every day
he doesn't take days off that [ __ ]
guy's never sick
if he's sick it's like the next day he's
running again you're looking at his
instagram it's hey it's a great day to
run
out there i did i think there's
something to
forcing your body to consistently and
constantly perform totally
yeah imagine uh like olympics
right you're in the olympics for
wrestling let's say
and you've got your whole entire life
is on one day if you get sick like
right anything bad happens that day yeah
you're done yeah those big moments like
that are [ __ ]
when you're you're so stressed out too
so your immune system is is super jacked
but i think there's a there's a thing
about peaking
for a big event whether it's a fight or
the olympics or something
versus maintaining consistent
conditioning they're very different
things
like a good example is tim kennedy tim
kennedy went through
uh i believe two camps in a row camp
fight got cancelled kept training went
through another full camp
and then when he fought calvin gastelum
he that guy's never tired and he was
gassing out in the fight
and there's a real good indication from
all involved that was because of over
training i know that when i would train
fighters
you could absolutely see when they would
overtrain it wasn't a big question
you'd go in you'd have a fighter that's
whatever level at
let's say let's say jiu jitsu because
i'm trying to jiu-jitsu with them and
every day you know they're they they
feel a certain level
and then one day you come in and you
train with them and they're just they
just suck
and i would tell them it's like hey man
two days off go eat some steak because
you would know
100 percent that they're over trained
yeah 100 what do you tell vegans
two days ago eat some steak yeah i would
tell them definitely eat some steak
you need that steak get some get some
steak
in you yeah just give him an elk just
give him just a
one good piece of back strap just
just try just trust me just eat it and
run through a [ __ ] wall
yeah that's the really weird thing about
watching people go through camps through
fight camps
and you know i really i basically don't
train fighters anymore like i used to
just because i don't have time anymore
but you would you would work so hard
to make sure that on that night
that they're there yeah they're there
and some people
get in the cage and they do better than
they would normally do
some people get in the cage and they
don't do as good and you got you know
jeremy stephens a great example
because especially when he first came
out started training
with me and he's not he's not with us
anymore but when he first started
training us like he was
a white belt in jiu jitsu but man
when he got in the cage he would just
elevate man
like mentally psychologically elevate
and he would perform way better in the
cage and then i've had other fighters
that
you'd get like they would be kicking
people's asses
in training and then they get in the
cage and it's a down step
and it's so hard to see that so hard
it's because
sometimes those guys are very committed
and they're working hard and
they're doing great and they just get in
there and just it's a psychological
thing
you know some people are dwarfed by the
moment it's very interesting to see
it's uh some people are also afraid of
the embarrassment of losing
that's a big one and they can't trust
the process
they can't just they can't just remove
themselves
and just go out there and fight do you
follow muay thai at all
a little bit but not to any great extent
there's a guy who uh george st pierre
brought into
uh his training camp when he was doing
the ultimate fighter uh
john jean-paul garbowsky and he's this
french savage muay thai fighter who
uh would basically get drunk every night
and showed up at uh
training at uh gsp's camp
drunk like he was out all night he was
in vegas right so the ultimate
fighter's in vegas drinks all night
shows up in the day the next day and
[ __ ] everybody up
and they're like this is so embarrassing
like guys were like devastated
like this guy literally came in holding
he's got a cup
like from like one of those to go cops
from one of the vegas clubs
he showed up in the morning see if he
can find it because it's kind of
hilarious
looks like a guy who should be driving
an uber okay he's not built like a
savage
he's just his mind is just he's got the
i don't give a [ __ ] and he's got it down
yeah and uh was a you know world
champion muay thai fighter
beat champions at limpini stadium in
thailand and
just a amazing fighter well
you know you always hear about the
comparisons of a black belt you just do
versus a wipeout right somebody doesn't
know anything and it's real real obvious
but when you get at a high level of muay
thai
it's very similar maybe not quite as
similar because there's always this idea
that well
you know i at least know if i throw up i
at least know as a human
how to throw a punch at least there's
some idea right there's some
like a normal human has no idea of how
to do an arm lock
zero you at least know have some concept
of how to throw a punch so there is like
a puncher's chance
but i remember the first time i sparred
with a real muay thai guy
i was i felt like a white belt i was
like oh okay
because i would think about throwing a
kick and i would get you know
kicked myself i would think about it and
get kicked
oh he knows exactly what i'm gonna do
just like a white belt jiu jitsu
you know you you can predict everything
that they're gonna do there he is so
yeah
he shows up i mean look no six-pack
i mean literally looks like a guy if you
saw that guy show up be like this dad
bob [ __ ] just
just he's he showed up straight from the
club i mean you can kind of tell
he's drunk and he gets in and starts
training with these guys
and see even get to some actual training
footage because they were they were
humiliated
i mean he was ragdolling these dudes and
beating the [ __ ] out of them and
dropping them
and it did it looks like nothing but
but it's the the problem you know he's a
world-class
kickboxer and these guys just really
have no idea
how to handle his movement and the the
skills that he has
yeah people underestimate people don't
think there's as much of a difference
between
like a black belt in jiu jitsu and what
would be considered an equivalent you
know world champion and muay thai
oh yeah this is a big deal step step in
the step in the ring and see how that
works out for you
guys sometimes get cocky about that i
had a buddy of mine he was taking an mma
fight
and he wasn't doing any striking he was
doing very little striking and he was a
really good ground fighter
and i said do you know how you can toy
with a guy on the ground
and they really have no chance he goes
yeah i go people could do that to you
standing
like you have to understand that the
fight starts standing it's not like you
start like it's not ebi rules where you
start on a guy's back and you know
you have a really good chance of
submitting him if you've got a great
rear naked choke this is not that yeah
this is you start
20 feet away from the guy and you're
standing
and you know you have to close that
distance you're not a great wrestler
either
yeah well that's the key component right
yes it's a giant factor because if you
if at least if you wrestle you can go
well at least i know i have a decent
chance of taking them down
yes a decent chance and even that's no
guarantee anymore well i go back to mark
schultz when he fought in the ufc
you know when mark schultz fought in the
ufc he only found one ufc fight but
that's when we got to see like
a world champion olympic gold medalist
top of the food chain wrestler
you're only on your feet if he wants you
to be like you you good luck throwing
that punch or kick because
you you have no chance he's going to
close the distance and drag you to the
ground unless you have
really good takedown defense and back
back then when he fought big daddy
goodrich
people didn't really have it unless they
were wrestlers they didn't really have
good takedown defense it hadn't really
been established
as like a part of the the whole skill
set of mma yet
you basically had what you came in there
with you're a karate guy that's what you
had
your muay thai guy that's what you got
you got to hope you land that elbow
before that guy clinches with you
and there is a there is a overall
strategic advantage to grappling
yes because you can close the distance
and if you're going to punch me you have
to get close enough
to you you have to make contact with me
which means i can grab a hold of you and
get you down that's why
that's why the early ufc it was like oh
you're gonna have to get close enough to
either punch or kick me and when you do
that
i can grab a hold of you and get you to
the ground also the chaos factor
especially in a street fight the chaos
factor is like bodies are flying
there's bad timing the clinch is happy
it's not like every
you know you'll you'll watch the
occasional street fight where a guy
tees off on some drunk guy and you know
lands the perfect punch and knocks him
out cold that does happen
but you know what also happens melee
wild [ __ ]
misses and then someone clinches and
then the
worst thing in the world is to fight a
grappler
who's good at takedowns when you're on
the concrete that is the
absolute worst thing in the world you
get suplexed on your head on the
concrete i mean
one of the worst things that could ever
happen you're basically getting hit in
the head by the world
yeah well this is why i to when i talk
about you know people say well what kind
of self defense
you you always say jiu jitsu for self
defense but you know you shouldn't let a
street fight go to the ground
here's here's how it works out if you
come to me and you want to fight me
and you like square off like in a boxing
stance i can run away from you
right i can just run away i can just run
away i'm going to get away from you i
don't want to fight you
if you want to kick me i can run away
from you like there's my primary
self-defenses i'm just going to run away
from you
when you grab a hold of me now
everything's different i can't run away
anymore now i have to actually know how
to
handle myself in a grappling situation
so that's why i start with jiu jitsu
and look absolutely learn boxing learn
muay more time learn wrestling
absolutely no doubt about it
but the very first thing you need to
learn is because if you want to fight me
i can run away if you square off and
you know you put your dukes up and say
come on or you push me
good i'm running away that's fine i'll
take that but as soon as you grab a hold
of me
now i got a problem because i can't run
in a weight run away real problem is the
ego where people don't know how to fight
and someone puts their dukes up and they
decide to see what they can do
they decide in that moment to either
fake it
or just like see if they can possibly
hit the guy and then they get
banked yeah somebody tease off on them
yeah i think that's uh
i think the the whole thing with cte
right now that's why i think the
popularity of jiu jitsu
is going to continue because it's a
large part of fighting same with
wrestling
grappling in general i think is going to
continue to
get more and more popular because
because of ct because you know as a
parent you're not looking hey i really
want my kid to be sparring a lot when
they're 13
right no there's not too many parents
that are saying that right now it's not
a good idea
yeah so i think but you still want your
kids to know how to fight
right so how are we going to do that
well we're going to teach them jujitsu
and wrestling and
let them have that base and then if they
get older hey should they know how to
throw punches absolutely should they get
in the boxing ring sometimes and do some
muay thai matches
absolutely you should absolutely do that
as a human
but you know you can do that when you're
17 maybe 16
you can start getting that stuff in but
the kids jiu jitsu i don't think there's
anything else better for them
i completely agree and i think with
martial arts with striking it's good to
know just to know distance
just to understand where you're safe and
where you're not safe and understand
tells understand what's happening when
someone does this when someone does this
and then this is coming when they do
this this is coming like you should know
that
because some people don't know that that
you you should know how to protect
yourself how to keep your hands up
how to duck under things you should know
that it should you should understand the
timing
you should understand distance and
timing those are important things but
[ __ ] swinging knuckles with some guy
in the street is so goddamn dangerous
because first of all you don't know what
he knows
and you're everyone's vulnerable
everyone every person that gets punched
in the face is vulnerable
and if you just want to have like some
sort of a kickboxing mattress a man on
the concrete
like i don't advise that no no i i
advise clinch
and trip yeah i advise get out of there
yeah get out of here
yeah definitely if someone wants to
start some [ __ ] with you you're
absolutely better off just swallowing
your ego and getting the [ __ ] out of
dodge
i that's the warrior kid books yeah
teach those kids
hey there's going to be problems there's
going to be bullies
if you can you don't need to fight them
yeah and
what's oh i have somebody hit me up you
know because i'm always telling people
change you just you trained jiu jitsu
had somebody hit me up you know i've
tried it uh
but i don't i want to try it i tried it
a couple times but i don't like to fight
and i'm like hey if you don't like the
fight to fight
you more than anyone else should learn
jiu jitsu because
if you know jiu jitsu you probably your
chances of having to fight will go down
a lot
just by the way you carry yourself just
the way by by the way you present
yourself
the chance of you having to fight go
down a lot also
with jujitsu you're involved in real
life
struggles the thing about like karate
sparring and a lot of point like light
sparring is
it's not the real chaos that comes with
an
actual fight whereas jiu jitsu is full
blast
someone's trying to get you it's full so
you get used to full blast
you get you get accustomed to it you
know what to expect if someone swings
for you and you clinch with them
you know what it's like to resist with a
100
non-compliant body you know someone's
like [ __ ] i'm really trying to get away
from you really
it's not like play sparring yes you can
go full out
len you know where this brings us right
back to
police officers yes well andrew yang
said it best he said
i think that every police officer should
be a purple belt oh that's purple belt
that's an incredible statement it's a
good level
right it's like an attainable level
within a couple of years but
with a couple of years man you've got
your ass kicked you've kicked some ass
you've you've like a purple belt is
basically a black belt who hasn't done
enough time yet
that's all it is i mean once you've got
past blue belt like blue belt is
i've put in the time i've learned how to
do some stuff and maybe i'll do this
i might make it i might make purple belt
like you basically
everybody who gets a purple you want to
grab them and go hang in there you are a
[ __ ] black belt
what's better to say and you're a black
belt in jiu jitsu you're gonna be a
black belt in jiu jitsu
just keep [ __ ] going you you already
have exhibited enough
technique that you could actually one
day achieve that
just keep going yeah the amount of
confidence and
and mental clarity that
cops would have if every cop was a
purple belt oh
it would be amazing amazing nothing
better that we could do
than to to somehow make that happen yeah
good idea for uh andrew yang
the horrible video of this guy involved
with this lady
and he's he's a cop and he's talking to
this lady and she's non-compliant and he
grabs her and
he [ __ ] brute strengths her to the
ground and throws her on her stomach and
then
gets in a rear naked choke and people
are filming this and yell it's a
terrible rear naked choke he tell he
sucks
the whole thing is terrible like i
couldn't imagine a black belt ever
handling it that way
ever ever first of all you wouldn't be
so threatened by her
she's not physically threatening at all
and you wouldn't want to bully her and
to show her that you could throw her
around like that
it wouldn't happen it wouldn't happen
fear
right that's fear kicking in and it's
fear not only of his ego but
he might be legitimately when's the last
time he put hands on somebody i mean if
you put hands on people a lot you know
you don't have to do what he did in that
situation the video but
you don't you know you know you don't
have to do that i think he's just a
[ __ ] when i'm looking at the video i'm
like
i just think he just wants to throw his
weight around which is another thing you
wouldn't do if you know how to fight
that's part of why a lot of people act
like that
is because they really don't know how to
fight and that's really they
really don't know how to do that to a
grown man so
when they're doing it to someone who
they can do it to because they're just
bigger they they do it they'll force
them to impose themselves be a bully
it's it's horrible to see but you
wouldn't you could see a black belt
doing that to somebody
the amount of confidence that he had
exactly
and it's the same thing with kids you
know i i posted something
a few months ago but it's you know some
some bully thing had popped up
and then i said hey if you want to stop
bullying um
you know have kids train jiu jitsu muay
thai wrestling they should have it in
school they should
be teaching kids in school and here's
the thing people thought
i said not only will it prevent them
from getting bullied
it will prevent them from bullying yes
which people don't understand people
cannot comprehend what that means and
it's exactly what you just said
if somebody actually knows how to fight
and you've been humbled and you've been
beat down
and you've been choked and you know what
that feels like and you know what it
means and you know how that feels
the chances of you look you could still
be an [ __ ] but the chances of you
becoming a bully are way
less way less than if you're insecure
and scared and have a
you know trying to make up for your ego
by abusing people that's who becomes
bullies
with kids and with adults 100
the more the more you train the more
secure you are the smaller your ego is
the more you're able to step back and
see things clearly you know that's one
of the
horrible things about that the george
floyd was
the other cops they're not detached from
the situation they're all wound up in it
and jiu-jitsu teaches you and fighting
teaches you
that if you do that if you allow
yourself to get wrapped up into stuff
you're gonna you're gonna make bad
decisions i think also for kids a lot of
the reasons why they do horrible [ __ ] is
because they have too much
[ __ ] energy oh they're all jacked up
with
young hormones oh yeah testosterone yeah
testosterone and
and angst and angst and
bro it's kind of fun right
you know like you it's kind of fun like
there's mayhem going on yeah and
what is that the right word am i a jerk
for saying that i don't know when i was
a kid that kind of mayhem i wanted to be
a part of it
you know if and and actually i was
talking to one of my la cop buddies
and i was asking him the difference
between like the the
92 riots was it 92 or 93 ronnie king
those those riots and these riots
those riots he was like those were the
people that kind of
instigated and started and perpetuated
those rides those were
real like gangsters like shot callers
were making those things happen
this one these riots were he was like
yeah these are kids
these are kids that drove down from
riverside these are kids that
you know and and sure some of their some
of their attitudes was like hey there's
been
you know injustices against police we
want to stand up to that got it
and then he said of course there's a
criminal element as well that are
legit normal robbery crews that are
saying oh cool we got some good cover
right now let's get in there and make
some
you know steal some stuff and we
probably won't get caught but that's
that's a a big difference so you do have
an element of kids that are like oh
there's some mayhem going on there's
some mayhem going on
guess what 17 year old boys like they
like mayhem they like mosh pits
right you love that stuff that was my
childhood
if there was some mayhem i wanted to
find it right and that's
that fuels these things normal boy
behavior normal boy behavior especially
when those boys are getting told don't
come out
and they're being locked up in houses
right now with their feet they've got
freaking steam
coming out of their ears and then all of
a sudden the cops are going to stand
down while you smash windows and steal
[ __ ] and everybody can get free sneakers
yes it had nothing to do with george
floyd it had so many things to do with
so many different steps
so many different factors that have
collided together on that one day
yeah yeah it's it's
man i don't know how this one ends up
man i don't know how it ends up either
it ends up with me getting the [ __ ] out
of l.a gone huh
it looks like it gone looks like it
i don't i just don't see the benefit i
want to come come back and visit a lot
but it's just it's just not
not a smart place you know i'm
unfortunately managed either
i'm rooted here unfortunately by the
ocean yeah because i'm an ocean guy yeah
and so there's really limited choices in
the world
yeah it really is yeah that's a
problem you know they kind of got me
you're that connected to the ocean what
is it about the ocean that you you
always post pictures of the sunrise in
the ocean
[Applause]
i don't think there's you know going
surfing just going just going in the
ocean and plus my
my life was kind of being in the seal
teams was
always we always had that that was part
of our
life you know part of our life was the
ocean growing up in the ocean
just there's some
i don't know you know i guess i guess
for me it's a huge like nature thing
right
you know people you should be you should
go outside
go outside and go hiking a mountain you
know go go to montana and hike
around see what that feels like go to go
to
idaho check that out go to the mountains
go to california mountain city you feel
different
you feel different you feel humbled you
feel small you feel perspective
so the ocean does that for me and it's
just
mind clearing right you go out surfing
like your mind is clear it's kind of
like jiu jitsu
hey you got to get out there you you
don't even know what you sometimes you
don't even
you know you get done with a good role
in jiu-jitsu and you say well
hey you don't barely even remember it
because your mind is just
gone you're just monkey mind zen this is
total zen
state same thing with the being in the
water for me surfing same thing like oh
i'm out here and my mind is just empty
it's monkey mind and
and i think that's really good for you
plus the fact it's humbling
plus the fact it's healthy so yeah i
just have a
a strong connection to the ocean i know
my
son's real watermen you know he's out he
serves all the
time i'd hate to do that to him and then
my little daughter's getting
her surfing on so yeah it's just one of
those things man
yeah i get it there's a reason why surf
towns like
like towns that are near the ocean are
chill you get humbled by that
like you take yourself seriously look at
that [ __ ] body of water over there
stupid
yeah you ain't [ __ ] uh you know people
say well what makes the seal team so
good
in one of the major components is the
ocean
because when you've got to do an
operation that involves the water it
just sucks
it just everything about it sucks
everything about it sucks
you're getting in a you know you're
parachuting from a plane into the water
it's night time you got boat you just
freaking parachute like
drifting around you got to get your
motor started it's freezing cold
boats flip over then you got to drive
that boat to the beach and you got to
drive
through the surf zone your weapons are
covered with sand you're freezing cold
it's just everything sucks everything
sucks about it so
when that's kind of your starting and by
the way you haven't even conducted your
operation yet
you haven't even started the operation
and you're freezing cold
you're tired your radio got flooded out
your night vision goggles are freaking
filled with sand
everything sucks and now you've got to
conduct your operation
so in order to survive that way on a
regular basis that's one of the things
that makes the seal teams good is we're
we're used to this one additional
component all the time
that you always have to deal with you
have to figure that out you have to be
able to
gut through it that's why in basic seal
training they just put you in the water
for a long time this puts you in there
we have to develop an attitude that
embraces the suck
oh yeah yeah for sure you actually enjoy
it
in some way some crazy way that you know
it sucks like that video that i always
quote
your video good dude i listen to that in
my head all the time and i'm listen i've
watched
the video a ton of times and listen to
it i've played it on this podcast at
least four times
but i hear it when i'm training like if
i'm running hills
and i'm [ __ ] exhausted and there's
like another 100 yards to get to the top
of that hill
i hear good good good you exhausted it
means you're [ __ ] doing it yeah
good well suck it up what what are your
what's your choice
what else are you going to think about
cry you know cry curl up in a ball
no it's like no actually good bring it
let's make this happen
yeah and if you can do i also do that in
the sauna when i'm
exhausted in the sauna and it's like 190
degrees and i'm
19 minutes in and you know doing a
30-minute session
i'm like good good sucks that means it's
going to
have a great effect on your body you're
going to get that hormetic effect this
is how you get the heat shock proteins
[ __ ]
hang in there good it's if you want to
if you want to do something that's
worthwhile
yeah it's going to suck yeah it's just
gonna suck and you might as well just
enjoy that part of it
yes yeah i mock myself too that's the
other thing i do
oh you make fun of yourself oh all the
time yeah i get pissed at that little
part of my brain
i'm like oh really you think you're
gonna think i'm gonna listen to you yeah
not happening
not happening i i did these like these i
put these things in the kids books
you know what i mean put those things up
you know those kids books
like there's a one of the kids books
talks about this hill horrible hill
you know like this what's this what's
going to face horrible hill
and dude what are you going to do you
know it's going to suck
just got to do it yeah you just do it
but the thing is it's
always sucks while it's happening it's
always [ __ ] horrible
but then when it's over it feels great
that you got through the suck
and i don't think most people who don't
experience suck
they don't experience that feeling of
conquering suck
yeah and that's the that's the important
thing to try and remember
right so you remember it i remember it i
remember what that
so even when it's sucking i'm like i
know how this is gonna feel i know how
this plays out
and you know what actually i know other
feeling you know is when you
don't do it yeah and the end of the day
comes you're like dude
that was pathetic you didn't even you
know you and that's just the worst
feeling that's the feeling that really
makes you sick
and so between that carrot and stick
carrot being like i know this is going
to be good and stick me
i know at the end of the day if i'm
putting my head on the pillow
and i was a [ __ ] that doesn't feel good
i don't want none of that
that's the worst feeling of all time
it's
being disappointed in yourself like it's
also when you're a type of person that
wants to achieve and so you're always
trying to get things done you're always
trying to push yourself
when you fall short because of cowardice
or because it is the worst feeling that
or
or just just failure any kind of failure
the reason why you would
one of the reasons why i mean at least i
can speak for myself personally
i do things so hard is because i've felt
that sting
of failure i you need to know what that
feels like especially when you quit
you need to know what quit yeah see
that's it
you need to know in your own and you
need to hear that that
[ __ ] sting feel that sting so that
when it comes up again you're like not
today [ __ ]
not today i've been here before
keep going keep going find a way
but there's something about good like
just even saying it it makes me smile
it really does it works it really does
work because it's an attitude changer
and i use the sauna sauna is really easy
it's not that bad
it's just [ __ ] 30 minutes you just
deal with it but there's something about
those last 11 minutes that you can get
in your head like [ __ ]
me really i probably get the good effect
if i just leave now
there's like all these little mind games
you play but if you just say
good does it suck good yeah i started
start smiling you can rationalize a lot
you can start rationalizing of why well
you know these last four minutes won't
really make that big of a difference
a shift in perception and i always
notice that from
listening to music when i run like
there's something about listening to a
great
[ __ ] song when a great song kicks on
when you're running
like if i'm i'm running in ted nugent's
stranglehold comes on
you know there's something about
stranglehold because it also has like a
double meaning right it's jiu jitsu
[ __ ] hat you know you like this so
when you hear that here i come again now
baby i can run i can run i can get extra
energy like where the [ __ ] is that
energy coming from
well it's coming from my mind right the
music stimulates my mind
it kicks in those endorphins and then
all of a sudden i got an extra gear yeah
well how come i can't just
conjure up that [ __ ] extra gear i
think you can
you you gotta figure out how to do that
all the time yeah that always is
horrible to see like in a in a fight
when a guy
either he loses a fight and after he
lose the fight he's raging he's all mad
but he was just gassed
right he was just gas where was that
where was it where was that right there
yeah two and a half minutes ago yeah i
mean sometimes it's just overcoming
anxiety for fighters sometimes it's just
when it's over and the plug is pulled
you know it's over and they're like [ __ ]
yeah and then they're angry and raging
because they realized they failed they
didn't manage their energy correctly
they didn't manage their mind their
anxiety
yeah exactly the same feeling of [ __ ]
loser
i'm so hard on myself man everything
i've ever done wrong everything i've
ever said wrong
just everything just i i could i'll be
i'll be in the middle of working out
sometimes and i'll think about it and go
[ __ ]
but that is also that that's what makes
yourself
yeah and that that keeps you going that
that makes you achieve it's like people
think that it's easy to just kind of go
out there and get things done
but it's not it's that's why most people
don't do it
yeah you know i i so i don't sleep a lot
right and sometimes people are like and
look i'm not saying you should
shouldn't sleep everyone should sleep as
much as they can i don't sleep a lot
people like hey no why don't you sleep
more
and i'm like bro i wish i could
like i wish there wasn't this little
thing in the back of my head going hey
hey you know you're actually that you
could be doing a lot more right now what
about this what about that what about
the other thing
like that's what's going on in my head
there's not something that's going uh uh
gee i have to get up like no there's a
thing in there going you better get up
you better get up they're tracking on
you they're watching you
you better get up yo it's happening
there's a bad guy out there
he's training harder like that's what's
in my head it's not in my head like oh
no no hey please
let the freaking let let the freaking
powers of the world allow me to go into
bed at night and just pass out and be
like oh i'm
i'm good i'm satisfied with my life
right now i wish i could feel that for
freaking
eight hours a night it ain't there it
ain't there
it's like oh people talk about staying
hungry i'm [ __ ] starving
i'm starving
all the time ah all the time like stay
hungry
yeah you have to like ah yeah
i know it never ends it doesn't end
that's the thing
and as soon as as soon as i get
somewhere as soon as i get somewhere i'm
like um
where else where i need to go i need to
go somewhere else yeah about getting
soft
yeah yeah always no matter what i've
ever done it was
one day there'll be a thing where i'll
become satisfied and calm
no with everything that's good that
comes now
there's an equal fear of becoming a
[ __ ]
there's a fear of now becoming lazy and
becoming like second
rate and just like god damn it there's
no end
yeah there's no so now i don't even
think there's an end no there's
definitely none of them
yeah that's that's what's funny about
shooting the uh shooting the bow
right is what's what i find funny about
shooting the bow is
anger aggression really doesn't help you
at all at all you know what it [ __ ] you
up yeah that's what i'm saying because
anger and aggression is all fast twitch
[ __ ] too it's all movement
whereas the bow is like you got to have
the mind of no mind
you got to just just execute and just
stay
completely focused on the task totally
detached from what's happening yeah and
you just got to sit there and
it's a new skill really oh it's totally
new and for
for me like in the competition that i
experienced the only competition i had
other than inside the gym um you know
training partners is
fighting and that's all fast stuff it's
all like
explosions and movements so any time
where there's danger
and and anxiety and fear your body's
geared up to go quick and move quick
but with hunting it's the opposite when
you're
drawing back on an animal all that
anxiety like you better get that quick
out of your head
yeah there's no quick there's execute
and calmness stay in the zone
nothing is exists other than the process
of executing the perfect shot it's the
same thing with shooting
you know you have you draw fast you move
fast you drop fast and then as soon as
you
punch out that weapon you gotta go boom
and like you just gotta let that thing
go
yes you used to see guys myself included
like
you ever shot headplates before yes like
yeah and you know there's six headplates
you'd see me or some someone else they
miss one and
it's if they don't if they don't let
that go right
then everything falls apart the wheels
fall off if they miss one and then they
try and shoot usually i would just miss
one and just keep shooting like it
didn't even happen and then maybe go
back and get it or you kind of have to
go back and get it
but if you go oh god how did i miss that
oh it's just a total and a complete and
utter disaster there's a great video
that tim kennedy put off of him uh
shooting on the range
and you know he puts dummy rounds in
with his regular rounds
and he hits the dummy round and click
and he's like look at that trigger
control
like trigger discipline because like
there was no flinch there was no nothing
it was just click
there's no movement it was perfect you
know which is what you're trying to
achieve what you're trying to achieve
you're trying you know the last thing
you want to see is click
ah you look some weird [ __ ] remember
when i first started shooting rifles
like uh that's what i would i was i
would experience that thing where you're
anticipating
the right you know 30 uh uh um
win mag 300 win mag so it's got a lot of
kick to it you know it's a boom it's
like a loud
loud kicking gun so um there was no
round in the chamber
and i pulled it and i saw myself doing
them like you [ __ ]
like you better learn how to stop doing
that one thing that's interesting is
learning how to shoot a bow radically
increased my accuracy with a rifle oh
yeah radically yeah because it's so
still
there's so much stillness and
everything's freehand right you're very
rarely shooting a rifle at an animal
freehand
usually trying to find a rest unless
it's like inside of you know 60 70 yards
you're probably going to try to rest
you're not going to shoot a 300 yard
shot
with a rifle freehand but with a bow
everything's freehand
so with a rifle i just knew that all it
was just squeeze squeeze squeeze let it
go off
just let it go squeeze boom like when i
started shooting
at uh tear and tactical shooting on the
range the easiest thing for me was a
rifle
i was like oh god all i have to do is
just squeeze and it'll the trigger will
go off i'm so used to
a bow where there's so many moving parts
and using your back and you're letting
it go off a surprise shot
it made a big difference in my rifle
accuracy yeah that that was
when uh when dudley was teaching me how
to shoot and andy was there too
so andy was like translating for me he's
like hey what he means
he's translating it to seal like pistol
shooting
and they're kind of like communicating
to each other and then andy said hey
what he's saying is like you know
front side focus i was like okay cool
got it you know and uh yeah it was
awesome to have
have freaking dudley i know the first
person that ever
shows me anything about archery is
dudley saying hey here's a bow and
here's exactly how to shoot you idiot
and i'm like
thank you that's pretty goddamn lucky
yeah i mean we're both real lucky in
that regard
i learned how to bow hunt from cam
haynes and john dudlin like
she's it's pretty lucky those are
those are like the world champions yeah
yeah
yeah that's uh that's jordan and kobe
bryant
jordan and lebron james completely yeah
100 yeah
it's uh we're very fortunate and it's um
there's something about hunting too that
once you it's it seems like when you're
looking
on the surface it seems so
straightforward and then once you start
doing it
it's very much like martial arts where
you're like god damn there's a lot of
layers to this [ __ ]
there's so many layers you know and then
when you're hanging out with a guy like
cam
or a guy like dudley and you hunt with
them and you see them hunt
you go oh like this is i get it this is
a black belt
oh this is some mundial's champion here
oh yeah
yeah that's exactly what it is so so
crazy
yeah so crazy to see those guys in
action and
just to be like listening to what
dudley's telling me about
what a freaking elk is gonna do yeah
he's gonna come over here yeah i'm like
well i guess that's just about to happen
oh and it just
happened yeah and it's it's madness and
then with dudley too
it's like he's so into cooking it too
he's so good at cooking it's like
you get the whole lifestyle thing from
him
you get like this learning how the the
art of archery
which really is an art form it's an art
form just like martial arts are
and then this moment of keeping your
[ __ ] together in the execution of a shot
and then the big payoff when that does
happen
and then the harvesting the animal
carrying it out
and then the meal that meal afterwards
when you've had a successful hunting
trip it's like
god damn when we were in camp in utah
and dudley made that neck
that uh neck roast with with jalapenos
and the
bell peppers and holy [ __ ] that was good
but it was also so good because you knew
what went down
you know you were there when he shot the
elk it's all it's all so crazy
it's it's it's so satisfying that i
can't imagine it not being a part of my
life
and not in that meat not being a part of
my diet
[Music]
just changes you yeah so it's it's
too bad that it's not more available to
people
yeah you know yeah it's not it's hard
it's a there's a high bar for
accessibility
it's it's very and we got real lucky oh
for sure we get to hunt at the deseret
ranch in utah which is this incredible
place it's a private
property it's all wild animals there's
no fences but it's private property so
there's not an overwhelming number of
people like there's a lot of guys that
they try to go on a public land and
unless you're willing to hike in 20
miles and there's a lot of guys that are
willing now to hike in 20 miles because
there's now this culture of these really
fit backpack hunters like these aaron
snyder type dudes
who put these [ __ ] heavy packs on and
they just go
they they're training for this moment
all year round
like aaron has this crazy set up in his
gym where he has this uh
elevated treadmill and then each the
treadmill on each side
has uh uh like a like an olympic
bar and you lift the bar so you're
holding weight
and you're going up this elevated
treadmill i'm like jesus
[ __ ] christ man but that's that's
what you have to do if you want to be
mountain fit
to be able to do that and that's the
barrier for entry
to go and do these public land hunts
everybody
stops at the trailhead everybody gets
out of their car and then how far are
you going to go
because he's willing to go 20 [ __ ]
miles in are you willing to go 20 miles
in
yeah that's gonna take eight hours and
then come 20 miles back out with a moose
on your back
freaking moose on your back that's
like that's totally legit yeah totally
legit that's as
legit as it gets yeah and most of those
guys all had to learn themselves they
ought to teach themselves and you know
they've all you know we're real lucky
that like
we get this amazing coaching so we're
getting this these giant even though
there's
so many layers to it and we're both ki i
mean i've been doing it now
i've been hunting for eight years bow
hunting for i guess
six six ish total rookie
you know i'm still like a blue belter
maybe maybe i'm like getting ready to be
a purple belt
maybe i might get my purple belt soon
but you know you go out with those guys
they're [ __ ] 10 degree black belts
and it's like there's even though
there's
you know this this barrier for entry it
is still
possible it's still possible but it's
just like jiu jitsu
it's like when you when you're talking
to that blue belt you're like keep
[ __ ] going
yeah and you can make it you can do this
you know speaking of which
uh i have to at least bring this up a
little bit
to clarify a little bit what i did to
john dudley
on the jiu jitsu map you broke his neck
you here's the only part that you're
missing
missing a little bit right so i'm giving
him
his wife uh like a like a jiu jitsu
private so you're from his name
and he's there little dud was there so
it was getting worse he broke his neck
in front of his wife and his son
so i'm just completely you know i'm
chilling and like hey this is this this
is that
and i'm not even i'm not even doing like
this that we
in one weekend andy john and me
we did we did archery which i had never
done before
then we did jiu jitsu which john had
never done before and then we went
on the wind tunnel which john had never
done before you know because
andy's like a sky god parachuting blah
blah blah
and so we did those three things it was
kind of like a cool weekend i mean
that's kind of an epic weekend really
let's be honest so it's jiu jitsu time
so i'm like okay cool so i'm going over
hey this is the guard this is the mail
i'm going over all the basic stuff i'm
i'm i'm just giving the basic overall
kind of concepts
so i get done with that you know and i'm
done
like i'm done i i'm just done i'm like
okay you know great it's good
introduction
and then dudley is like well let's go a
little bit
and i'm like that's the wrong language i
would have pulled him aside come here
so so he's like let's go a little bit
and even that you know what i'm totally
cool with that of course he wasn't i he
wasn't mean and he would
wasn't thinking he was gonna be that
wasn't it he's he he wants the
experience yeah yeah i shouldn't have
even said let's go a little bit he was
like he was like hey can we
can we try it you know something like
that just being cool and i'm like
absolutely man
no problem so so i lay down on the
ground
right and i'm like he says well
what should i do i go you know just
attack me so i lay down on my back i'm
like just attack me
and guess what he did what he did he
freaking attacked me
he like came at me and dudley's
a big strong athletic guy he's six what
is he six
five at least yeah so he caught me
[ __ ] he grabs it and i'm chilling you
know i'm just like okay cool
he he comes at me i think i he like
grabbed me and so i kind of replaced
guard
and then i sweep him and i'm not and so
i'm mounted and all this is just
pretty chill and i put in uh
uh ezekiel choke right which i have a
little yeah nogia's equal choke i have a
little
i have a little good technique for doing
it but no big deal so i put in the
ezekiel choke
he's this is the thing that i really
wish i should have explained more
because we hadn't rolled
i wasn't like hey when you start to feel
like you gotta you gotta tap out right
he knew to tap out but i kind of figured
everyone knows how to tap out so i put
the choke in on him right
well he doesn't know what to do so he
he's grabbing me and he's pulling he's
squeezing
me so he's on the bottom i'm mounted
i've got the ezekiel choke in
and in order to defend himself in his
own mind
he's squeezing me into him
which the way i do my ezekiel choke it
hurts i mean it compresses the choke
even more
and so what are you doing specifically
basically i put my hand i make a fist
and i put my fist in my sternum and then
i
you know grab the forearm here and then
arch my shoulders so there's the neck
right here
it closes it right so it's putting the
fist into the fist into right
it's a it's a trach it's an air choke
it's gnarly okay
and so i'm just doing this and you can
see that hole and you shrug
but as i'm doing this he's panicking and
pulling me into him oh jesus and he only
did it for a second and then he
and then he taps out and i was like yeah
you know and i wasn't
i was just like oh you know boom and
then he taps
and then the rest of the stories i guess
i didn't know a lot about the rest of
this
i didn't know any of the rest of the
story because he didn't want to see him
feel like a baby yeah it fractured like
his hyoid bone
and then it built calcium up around it
so he calls up andy one day
and he goes dude i think i got throat
cancer because there's something growing
in my throat
and he goes the doctor gets an equity
and he's like hey did you do something
to your neck because there's a
there's a hairline fracture that's not
now calcium deposit around it
and he's like oh i know what happened so
i guess
in my defense why didn't you just get
him in like a head and arm dude or
something it wasn't that it was it
wasn't like a big deal
it wasn't it wasn't crazy it wasn't
crazy it was just normal it'd be like
if if you grabbed somebody that showed
up here's like hey you know hey can you
roll with me you'd be like oh cool and
you'd put them in a kind of whatever
presented itself maybe you'd arm lock
them
maybe you'd do a commercial problem is
when you get used to doing
certain types of chokes and then you're
doing it to someone who doesn't
especially that where you've got a fist
yeah in the neck
and i this is i guess this is the only
thing uh
he make no mistake about it even though
i was just chilling
he was not he was going level seven
berserker mode on me
and he's such a good athlete you know
that's the thing about people that have
never
done jujitsu when they're doing it with
someone who's a black belt they probably
feel like they can just kind of go crazy
and you'll just absorb it and deal with
it and so they just
try it let's see what happens when i go
crazy so now he holds this over my head
you know he should he broke his neck oh
i know i know one day i'm like i'm like
we're up in montana and i said hey man
he's like
he sits like he was at my house he's oh
thanks for having us over i go bro
you you know you taught me how to do
this you brought me up here you take me
hunting like you're doing all this
awesome stuff man
i you know you're the man dude i really
appreciate he goes yeah you know what
you did for me
i'm like what he goes broke my neck
[Laughter]
it's awful bro oh it's all good now
though right
oh yeah is it not bothering him anymore
oh i don't know about that
i thought you meant it's all good
between us it's all good between us he
just sent me a new bow we're freaking i
think every time he swallows he thinks
about you
no he coughs oh no he coughs
hopefully i mean i haven't talked to him
about it i don't like to bring it up a
lot
but so there's something in there that's
[ __ ] with his throat something in
there is making him cough so they'd have
to probably get in there and scrape it
so while we're hunting he would be like
and then he'd look at me oh no i'm just
thinking oh i'm such a
such a horrible person oh no it it's
you know i was i always say like uh you
know i dean lister i had
been dean lister's training partner for
20 something years
up until recently he never hurt me and i
never heard him
never i mean until recently yeah because
he he ended up hurting me
and he ended up hurting me in the
dumbest possible way
i show up to class this was like this is
over a year ago because i it hurt my
archery for a while
i show up to class late right and he's
teaching and we're just gonna roll but i
come out and he's like finishing the
class
and i'm cold and i'm just just getting
on the mat
and he says oh let me show let me show
something he goes here lay down and he
gets a
he gets a straight like he gets an
americana on me
or a camira but anyways he's like hey
try and get out by straightening your
arm
and the whole class is watching he goes
try and get out by straightening your
arm i'm
and i go okay cool and so he puts me
across he gets a cross side he puts the
i think it was i think there's an action
uh a camira he says
he says all right now try and this is in
front of the class you're going to see
he's like straight arm
he's about to straight he's about my arm
is here and he's about to straight
he wants me to try and get out by like
doing almost like a hitchhiker escape or
something
so he says uh he says try and get out by
straightening your arm i go okay
i straightened my arm and he just in a
millisecond
and you could hear it arm locks me
totally destroyed my arm uh no not
totally it was injured very bad the
first time in my life i had to get a
sling
this bro this guy comes over to me dean
lister
and he goes bro and he's all he's such a
nice guy
he's all bro i'm so sorry and he goes i
didn't know your elbow wasn't very
flexible
i go bro it's an elbow elbows aren't
flexible
they're bone dude i didn't know your
elbow wasn't flexible ah
d needs a dna test because i know he's
at least 86 percent neanderthal
yeah at a minimum the way his neck and
his shoulders move together
you can see that dude with like a a big
club for sure
and the total total mutant and a savant
on the jiu jitsu mountains
yeah a complete savant on the jujutsu
map well he's the literally the missing
lin he's the link i shouldn't say the
missing link the link to
jiu jitsu expanding it to the leg like
modern jiu jitsu it's 100 percent
dean lister the statement that he made
to john danaher has become world famous
because dana heard said it on my podcast
he said dean lister said to him
why would you enjoy why would you ignore
50 of the human body
yeah and donoher being the [ __ ]
genius that he is was like why would you
enjoy yeah why would you
so would you ignore it most of the like
you know all these new things that are
coming out now
right yeah uh you know you see gordon
ryan just
insane all these guys that are really
attacking legs now and by the way just
like dean gordon's not only good at
attacking legs he's good at everything
but i i was asking dean because i
watched you know dean's done all these
moves to me
for years you know and uh
just just over and over again right this
is what we do it's what this is what
we've been doing we've been doing it
since he won adcc when
when eddie beat hoyler when dean won
when he beat cockaraco in the finals
with uh
what they now call 5050 which he and i
called
cockaraco after that we called that
cockroach no one started doing it for
another
many many years probably 10 years
regularly i was there that year
oh yeah and i wasn't there that year i
was i was there when eddie
won in san diego we were all i competed
in san diego dean competed in san diego
and eddie competed in san diego for the
trials i was there for that too
eddie won yeah uh dean won
i lost to big country roy nelson oh wow
yeah
yeah and i did because i wasn't very
tactically smart
i scrambled to a position and i tried to
get
a matter of fact i got a crucifix
because that was kind of one of my go-to
moves get a crucifix and i'd get a choke
from there
when i should have taken the back and
gotten points and i didn't and
roy nelson who is a great guy and he's a
total stud
uh he i got the crucifix position and he
like
powered out of bounds and so then and he
he beat because he's a much better
uh wrestler than me and awesome at jiu
jitsu too
anyways uh when he won that like we were
doing this stuff
so anyways right
probably six months ago or three months
ago
i was asking dean i said hey dina are
you starting to see things that
you didn't know right when your watch
because he watches
you know i said are you starting to see
jiu jitsu things that you didn't
that you didn't know like foot lock
stuff and he's like he's like yeah about
three or four months ago i started
seeing some things that i didn't think
of
so that's how long it took people to get
to and then start to
develop their own stuff which which is
pretty crazy well it's fascinating
that once the game moved into this sort
of leg lock
heavy style that so many guy like
craig jones and gordon ryan and there's
you know gary tonan there's so many of
those guys that you're seeing this game
getting
tighter and tighter with leg locks yeah
and the way john donahue examines
everything too
because donahue's body is broken he
can't really compete anymore
i mean he has an artificial hip he's got
an artificial knee his body's really
[ __ ] up
and his the his other knee is really
unstable
so he can roll but he can only roll very
controlled with guys who understand his
physical limitations and then you can
see
how he understands positions you can get
a lot out of rolling with him there's a
great video actually of gordon ryan
rolling
with john donahue and obviously they're
not using strength they're just
flow rolling but you you see
how tactical he is and how
ahead of every position he is and how
his
deep understanding of it and part of it
is because
he's teaching these guys and he's
teaching them
from a position where he can't really do
it himself he can do it but he can't
can't compete he can't roll right right
but but but he has the mind for it so
he's seeing it from the outside
and he's also this [ __ ] really genius
human being
yeah so he's able to break this down and
then he has this core group of
badasses that understand what a great
pleasure it is
to have this genius teach you i mean
it's not a coincidence that
that whole enzo gracie team has become
the one of
the biggest threats like that the whole
team is filled with [ __ ] murderers
yeah and they're just to again emphasize
the point is
leg locks are a part of the game
and there was a time period where people
thought that leglocks would
change the game completely and at a
certain point
the defenses for the leglocks become
known and all of a sudden you have to go
back to
the other parts of jujitsu and that's
why you see guys like tonan right
he doesn't always win with heel hooks
but you have to address them or you will
lose
right and yeah those guys it's really
cool to see those guys coming up
i mean it's such saying it coming up
like i'm
like like but i'm watching this
development which i was at kind of
ground zero with dean lister
and the crazy thing is dean lister
he has like a like a crazy savant mind
where
i would create one thing
for every whatever
for every 20 things that dean created
it's probably like eddie and i don't
know eddie as well as you do but
just the creative part of his brain is
what the most powerful thing was yeah
and then once people
saw it they're like okay now we can
build upon this yeah for eddie it's 100
the creative part of his brain also the
fact that when i met eddie
he hated lifting weights he wouldn't
lift weights because i would try to get
him to lift weights like come on let's
look forward to
i'm [ __ ] lifting [ __ ] like you can go
lift weights so so he was this little
tiny guy
and he had to rely on technique so he
had to rely on trickery
plus he was a musician right so he's
always this creative
guy and he smoked a lot of weed too so
he's always thinking about things
outside the box
and he's also this guy that doesn't like
people telling him that he's wrong
so like you know like you can't do it
that way he's like oh really hm
let's see if i can and then he would
find a way to do it and you know and
he just developed all these like weird
entries into things and these weird
setups that people didn't see coming
and once he sort of improved upon these
and then started expanding upon them and
then developing that whole 10th planet
system i mean
really it's insanely creative system
that's just developed
based on his ability to just think
outside the box
i had jeff glover in my training in my
gym for a long time teaches
him he's the same thing where he's small
he's crazy flexible
he smokes a lot of weed and like he
would just do
wild things wild things i was at a g i
was at
i was actually at adcc and i was with
myself my son was probably like
nine or something and we're there
watching and jeff glover's about to
compete this was before
i really was friends with jeff was he
doing that donkey guard thing
back then he was doing everything he the
donkey guard hadn't become super popular
but he was kind of in the beginning
stages of it so i'm sitting there next
to my son and we're at adcc so it's it's
a small thing you know i go i
and i said to my son you know go hey
watch this guy that's about to come out
he's crazy
and glover comes out and he like just
he falls on his back flips inverted
guard and starts like
just going insane just doing insane
things
and you know the rest of the matches are
two guys you know playing patty cakes
and looking for the take down
glover comes out falls down freaking
just doing all kinds of wild stuff and
then submits the dude in
30 38 seconds and my son looks me he
goes
he goes i thought you meant like crazy
and he goes
i didn't know you meant crazy and i go
yes he thought you meant like brutish
yes brutus crazy he didn't think i meant
just weirdly
what that weird creative thing is yeah
that's one of the best things about
learning jiu jitsu from a small person
like those small guys they figure out
how to get around things i mean there's
been a bunch of
you know hoiler gracie's a great example
of it too eddie
glover yeah yeah that's that's why i'm
never a good that's why i'm a bad person
to introduce people to jiu jitsu right
because they just think oh yeah of
course you're a gorilla
you know you outweigh me by 40 or 50
pounds
yeah i love i used to always have jeff
glover on standby at my gym like oh
you don't oh yeah okay go go train with
that guy over there see what happens
and when jeff goes against a like a big
strong guy
you're gonna get some yeah they really
get so disappointed in themselves it's
so sad
he said he said the easiest people for
him to roll with
were big like muscular guys really he
says the easiest people
for him to roll with are big muscular
guys like big muscular guys he says
i i love them i love rolling with them
they're so easy that's so crazy because
most people get injured mm-hmm
rolling with like gloves freaking
flexible no
his i think his i think his neck's
jacked up now oh is it now yeah
that's the thing that gets everybody is
the goddamn neck the net you know
because very few guys really strengthen
their neck correctly either
i think the neck is one thing that you
absolutely should strengthen
i think you can get away with not
lifting weights and doing jiu jitsu but
i don't think you can get away with not
strengthening your neck for very long
yeah that's uh it's one of those things
and it connects you to the rest of your
freaking body you also
use it you use it more than you think
you know especially me i was uh
my my favorite technique is probably
head and arm choke
and you're using your neck to secure
that arm and once you develop a feel
for holding an arm in place with that
neck then that gets a workout band
you know you really you use it a lot
more than you think and if you can
strengthen your neck
it's just it's such a big advantage it's
also a big advantage in avoiding getting
hurt because it strengthens the whole
chain from the top of your spine all the
way down
you know that's why i'm such a big fan
of that iron neck i just used it right
now right
right before the podcast i was doing it
i do it every [ __ ] day man i put that
i have one
i bought one love it they emailed me a
bunch of like bro how do you like it
it's all good that's [ __ ] awesome man
between that
and you know there's a few other back
exercises and stuff that i think are
critical
strength in the lower back too because
it's another thing that guys always get
jacked is their lower back
yeah you know the weird thing is people
people people's necks get jacked up
regardless like there's people that go
through life doing whatever paperwork
and they end up with a bad neck
neck is a vulnerable thing so if you
don't take care of it especially when
you are abusing it when you are getting
choked when you are not tapping
it's uh one of those things i judge
people in their necks
on the size of their neck yeah if i see
someone a little skinny
are you doing man yeah do some go do
some bridges it just doesn't seem like
it would be a good thing to have
that's that's the thing that holds your
head on i can't wait
for the future when your neck is all
jacked up and you go in and they just
put you in surgery for two hours
and you come out you got a metal spine
that's what's going on oh yeah i'm gonna
be the first person i'm
i'm right in line you want to give me a
metal spine or any metal
components inside my body i'm 100 down
let's make it happen he's got a
fake disc eddie's got a titanium
articulating disc
where lower back his his lower back had
been so
smashed and suppressed that um his you
know that's one of the things that's why
men when they get older they they shrink
as your discs get squashed
to the point and they start touching you
get stenosis
do you think you can go too far with
flexibility that it starts to injure you
over the long term
well i don't think you can go too far
with flexibility but flexibility without
strength
perhaps because maybe that inflexibility
like maybe you'll get like some muscle
damage
you know when you're trying to push too
far that'll prevent you from getting
disc damaged
maybe that's just speculation but i
think
it's critic it's just so critical to
strengthen your back man
i mean i'm always doing reverse hypers
and i do all these different
like uh little back extensions i just
think
strengthening that whole column and yoga
in particular
and then the neck the iron neck i just
think that whole thing
it's like too many guys just rely on
their workouts to strengthen that
and they don't take it as like hey i
really like doing jiu jitsu i really
like doing muay thai
i want to put in the time to work out
these areas
how's eddie's back now it's not 100
it's it still [ __ ] with him a little
bit but he's rolling again but he's got
a fake discs
a disc it's a titanium disc that they
replace the smooshy part
with this thing that rolls and moves but
it still creates some inflammation
whenever
look um i know i had ronnie coleman here
last week i know i listened to it and
his whole back is
all fused and it's horrible man i mean
he can't walk
and you know he's the king greatest
olympian of all time i mean he's a
[ __ ] amazing
pro bodybuilder eight time mr olympia i
watched that i watched the documentary
yeah did you see the documentary really
good man really just
what a good guy great guy what a nice
guy couldn't be nicer couldn't and in
pain
in [ __ ] agony and just friendly and
oh wouldn't wouldn't have it any other
way
and he talks about the the days that he
like he was talking about uh
squatting 800 pounds and that uh like
he only he said he was gonna do it for
two reps and after the two reps
he could i could have gotten more and to
this day he thinks he should have got
more
that's what we were talking about
earlier right at night
that's why he's a champion i mean that
really is that that's what made him a
champion
did you watch the vid the uh the west
side versus the world
documentary no it didn't with louis i
got to interview louis
i have yeah piece of his equipment too
that belt squat machine okay which is
amazing it puts all the weight on your
on your hips
versus on your back he's a [ __ ] wild
dude
i want to go out there and hang out oh
he would love you man
he would love you yeah he's you would
love him too man he's
he that is who louie is and he's got
this [ __ ] gym filled with barbarians
oh yeah just all they're doing is just
trying to lift the maximum amount
of weight they can lift it's insane
mikey my kid watched that
and he you know i think he's just all
about it now right outside
him and his little buddies talking about
louis simmons you know
he's controlling harder go heavier i
mean jamie and i were in his office
interviewing them and
that's where we did it we actually oh
you went out i did the podcast at west
side yeah i was in columbus doing
stand-up and
i just i had to interview him that's
awesome i just knew i knew just like
i want to get the guy in his gym too
it's just [ __ ] amazing
he gave us a tour of the gym and then we
did a podcast at his desk
it was awesome what a rare human being
yeah they don't make them like louis
simmons but also a genius like here's a
guy who figured out like his disc was
[ __ ] up
and they were like we're gonna fuse you
and he's like well let me think of this
something made it compress i'm gonna
figure out something to make it
decompress
and strengthen that area and that's
where the reverse hyper came from
which i think should be a staple in
every gem that reverse hyper machine for
strengthening the lower back and then
actively decompressing i've never found
anything better
that's all in louis simmons mind it came
out of his own brain because of his
injury
that he came back from after and was
squatting whatever
729 world record at whatever 62 years
old yeah but i wouldn't recommend any
things he do
he does i mean here's a guy who got his
biceps reattached and then blew it out
because it was too annoying
to not be able to work out so he just
went back to working out and popped
snap back off no they all called back so
he's got no biceps
just pulls back crazy animal
he get his shoulder redone they gave him
an artificial shoulder goes back to the
gym and they're like you're gonna max
out today
his friends made him max out after his
shoulder surgery
with an artificial shoulder like okay
like just that's just the culture
yeah the culture is it doesn't matter
injuries don't matter in the uh
in the documentary one of the guys was
saying
my goal was to hurt louie when he came
in the gym
my goal was to hurt him i wanted him to
get hurt
i wanted to push him so hard that he got
hurt
this is one of his buddies one of his
friends
one of his training partners my goal was
to hurt him that's that culture though i
mean that's how you develop such a
legendary place
you have to have the sensibilities are
beyond what a normal person would
consider
a prudent thing to do yeah and if people
the people that could withstand that
kind of pressure became champions yeah
became world record holders it's all
about the mind jocko that's what nobody
knows more than you
we just did three hours dude let me give
you a covid test now it's 3 30. let's
get some
all right let's get some thank you
brother appreciate you man bye everybody
[Music]
you